BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE
ON CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITOL. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 112 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. TODAY IS OUR FIRST
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING ON LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ISSUES. WE ARE JOINING. WE ARE
JOINED BY REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS, AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD, EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT,
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEPARTMENT,
DEVELOPMENT BOARD, LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE, AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THERE ARE
FIVE ISSUES ON THE AGENDA THAT
COVER MAJOR GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS, NONE OF WHICH WERE
PART OF LAST WEEK'S EARLY ACTION
AGREEMENT. WE WILL ALSO HEAR
GENERAL STATUS UPDATES FROM EDD
AND THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING, SO WE ARE NOT TAKING
ANY VOTES TODAY. WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AFTER ALL,
DISCUSSION ISSUES ARE COVERED TO
ENSURE WE HAVE TIME FOR
EVERYTHING. ON TODAY'S AGENDA,
WE ARE ASKING PRESENTERS TO KEEP
THEIR TESTIMONY UNDER FIVE
MINUTES. I WOULD ALSO ASK MY
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO KEEP
THEIR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
CONCISE. WOULD ANY MEMBERS LIKE
TO SAY ANYTHING BEFORE WE BEGIN?
SEEING NONE, BEFORE WE BEGIN
DISCUSSION, LET'S ESTABLISH
QUORUM CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR WAHAB HERE.
DURAZZO. HERE. NEWMAN. HERE.
SATO WE HAVE A QUORUM, THE
CONSULTANT NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED. LET'S BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST ISSUE. OUR FIRST
ISSUE IS GOING TO BE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
OUR PANEL WILL BE ANDREW MARCH,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. CHAS,
ALAMO, LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE, ADELE BURNS, DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. THANK
YOU. ISSUE ONE COVERS THE YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AT DER.
FIRST WE WILL HEAR FROM ANDREW
MARCH, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU YOU WILL BE
TIMED. YEAH. GOOD MORNING.
ANDREW MARCH, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA,
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
DELAY OF THE $25 MILLION SLATED
FOR THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM IN 2425,
AND TO DELAY IT OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS, THIS IS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SOLUTIONS THAT
INCLUDE APPROXIMATELY 734.5
MILLION OF DELAYS. APPROXIMATELY
355 MILLION OF THOSE OF THOSE
DELAYS WERE ADOPTED IN THE EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE LAST WEEK. SO
THESE ARE SOME OF THE REMAINING
ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION. THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM LEO? GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. CHAZ ALAMO
WITH THE ANALYST'S OFFICE, NO
SPECIFIC COMMENTS ABOUT THE
DELAYS HERE IN THIS ITEM. I
THINK WE NOTE THAT THIS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
PACKAGE OF DELAYS FOR WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS, AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THE LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO RETHINK
THE SPECIFIC OUTLINES. AND THE
DETAILS OF WHAT PROGRAMS WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO DELAYS, EITHER
WITHIN OR BEYOND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S, ANTICIPATED
SORT OF TOTAL TARGET FOR THE
DELAY AMOUNT. IN PAST BUDGETS,
THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAS CONSIDERED
ALTERNATIVES TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PACKAGE AND
COULD DO SO AGAIN THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU, NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. MISS
BURNS. GOOD MORNING, FOLKS. A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE. SO I'M I'M
VERY HAPPY TO SHARE THAT THE
FIRST ROUND OF THE CALIFORNIA
OPPORTUNITY YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP
GRANT HAS BEEN A HUGE SUCCESS,
JUST IN TERMS OF THE LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT THAT WE'VE HAD AT
EVERY STAGE OF THE GRANT, AND
THIS REALLY SPEAKS TO THE NEED
FOR THE FUNDING, AND I APPLAUD
THE CHAMPIONING OF THIS FUNDING
SOURCE AND REALLY THE NEED THAT
IT'S FILLING, SO AS I SHARED
WITH YOU IN THE SUMMARY UPDATE,
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP COMMITTEE FIRST
CONVENED IN EARLY 2023 AND WAS
EMBARKED ON WORK TO DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ALL OF US
AROUND THREE AREAS DEFINITIONS
OF YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP ADVISORY
ON THE MOST EFFECTIVE USE OF THE
FUNDS, AND ALSO HOW WE AS A
STATE ORGANIZE AROUND YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP. AND THAT GROUP
IS CONVENING REGULARLY AND IS
WORKING TOWARDS A REPORT TO ALL
OF US BY JUNE OF 2024. SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT. AND WE ARE
DRAFTING THAT AND WILL BE
GATHERING PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT
IN THE COMING MONTHS, BUT OF
COURSE, WE KNEW THAT WE NEEDED
TO DEPLOY THE FUNDING BEFORE
THAT REPORT WAS DUE, SO THAT WAS
ADVISORY AROUND THE USE OF THE
FUNDING WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THAT THE GROUP EMBARKED
UPON. AND WE HELD A PUBLIC
COMMENT PROCESS AROUND THE MOST
EFFECTIVE USE OF THE FUNDS, AND
WE GOT JUST A TREMENDOUS
RESPONSE. WE HAD 53 WRITTEN
COMMENTS. WE HAD 90 PEOPLE
ATTEND A PUBLIC MEETING AND
SPEAK UP AND SHARE THEIR PUBLIC
COMMENTS, I PERSONALLY READ
THROUGH 120 PAGES OF PUBLIC
COMMENT, AND IT WAS REALLY,
REALLY VALUABLE TO GET THAT
ENGAGEMENT AND TO GET THAT INPUT
FROM FOLKS AS TO HOW TO MOST
EFFECTIVELY USE THE FUNDS. SO
WE, IN NOVEMBER OF 2023, WE
ANNOUNCED THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
FUNDING AT THE NOVEMBER NATIONAL
APPRENTICESHIP WEEK EVENT THAT
WE HOSTED ON THE SUBJECT OF
YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP, AND WE
OPENED UP THE SOLICITATION FOR
PROPOSALS ON FEBRUARY 5TH OF
THIS YEAR. AND BY THE MARCH 15TH
DEADLINE, WE GOT AN INCREDIBLE
192 PROPOSALS, WHICH VASTLY
EXCEEDED ALL OF OUR
EXPECTATIONS. SO ONCE AGAIN,
TESTAMENT TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS FUNDING TO SUPPORT
OPPORTUNITY YOUTH IN IN GETTING
INTO APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. SO
WE RECEIVED PROPOSALS IN FOUR
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES. WE HAVE
PRE-APPRENTICESHIP PLANNING
GRANTS, APPRENTICESHIP PLANNING
GRANTS, PRE-APPRENTICESHIP
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS AND
APPRENTICESHIP IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS. AND ONE OF THE KEY
THINGS WE FOCUSED ON IN
EVALUATING PROPOSALS WAS LOOKING
FOR ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAD
EXPERIENCE SERVING OPPORTUNITY
YOUTH AND HELPING THEM ENTER
INTO EMPLOYMENT. SO THAT WAS ONE
OF THE KEY AREAS. SO WE HAVE
FINALIZED THE REVIEW AND WE ARE,
AS WE SPEAK, PREPARING THE PRESS
RELEASE AND THE AWARD LETTERS
THAT ARE VERY SOON TO GO OUT.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
SNEAK PEEK, WE HAVE 51 PROPOSALS
THAT WE HAVE SELECTED FOR
FUNDING, AND IT'S ROUGHLY ONE
THIRD APPRENTICESHIP
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS, ONE THIRD
PRE-APPRENTICESHIP
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS AND ONE
THIRD PLANNING GRANTS. WITH A
LITTLE BIT MORE EMPHASIS ON THE
APPRENTICESHIP PLANNING GRANTS
AND THE AIM THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS IS TO
SERVE ROUGHLY 2000 INDIVIDUALS,
AND WE JUST WE GOT SUCH AN
INCREDIBLE NUMBER OF QUALITY
PROPOSALS THAT WHILE WE
INITIALLY INTENDED USING $25
MILLION OF THE FUNDING WE'VE
BEEN ALLOCATED SO FAR, THERE
WERE SO MANY AMAZING PROPOSALS.
WE WENT BACK TO OUR FINANCE TEAM
AND ULTIMATELY WE'RE AWARDING
$31.1 MILLION IN THIS FIRST
ROUND OF THE GRANT. SO, IN
ADDITION TO THE KHÎI GRANT,
WE'VE BEEN DILIGENTLY HIRING IN
THE AREAS OF PROGRAM SUPPORT,
THE FUNDING TEAM, AND OUTREACH
ROLES. AND WE'RE IN THE FINAL
INTERVIEW STAGES ON THE PROGRAM
SUPPORT AND THE FUNDING TEAM. SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE ONBOARDING
THOSE FOLKS IN THE COMING MONTHS
TO REALLY SUPPORT WITH THESE 51,
BUT REALLY THE 192 PROPOSALS,
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH WE COULDN'T
FUND THEM ALL, OF COURSE WE ARE
HERE TO SUPPORT ALL OF THEM IN
DEVELOPING PROGRAMS, SO THE NEXT
STEPS WE ARE GOING TO BE
FINALIZING AND EXECUTING THOSE
$31 MILLION IN CONTRACTS AND
GETTING AT LEAST THE FIRST 20
MILLION OF THOSE ENCUMBERED
BEFORE THE JUNE 30TH DEADLINE.
SO WE'RE ON TRACK FOR THAT.
WE'LL, OF COURSE, BE ONBOARDING
THE NEW TEAM MEMBERS, AND WE DO
PLAN TO DO FUTURE ROUNDS OF THE
KHÎI GRANTS, POSSIBLY WITH A
FOCUS ON FUNDING THE SUCCESSFUL
PLANNING GRANTS FROM THIS FIRST
PHASE, TO HELP THEM LAUNCH AND
SCALE THEIR PROGRAMS. I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES, DO YOU HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANEL? SENATOR DURAZO, I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU. I'M
PERSONALLY VERY EXCITED AND VERY
PROUD OF HAVING MOVED THAT
FORWARD. SO AND TO SEE YOU
ACTUALLY DOING IT REALLY, REALLY
MAKES ME EXCITED. NOT ONE OF
THOSE WORDS JUST PUT OFF AND PUT
OFF. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE YOUTH, SENATOR
SERRANO. SO IN IN THE RELATION
TO OUR BUDGET, WHAT HAPPENS TO
THESE YOUTH AFTER THEY GO
THROUGH THEIR APPRENTICESHIP?
YES. SO, AS YOU KNOW, THE
APPRENTICESHIP IS EMPLOYMENT,
RIGHT? AND SO IT'S A JOB THAT
THEY'RE IN AND, AND
HISTORICALLY, SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
80 AND 90% OF APPRENTICES GET
HIRED ON AS FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
BY THE EMPLOYERS THAT THEY'RE
APPRENTICING WITH. SO THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY THE HOPE. AND THE
INTENTION IS THAT AFTER THAT,
THEY ARE THEY ARE EMPLOYED. AND
THIS GRANT DOES ALSO FUND SOME
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN WE'RE
SUPPORTING YOUTH WHO ARE OUT OF
SCHOOL WHO ARE DISCONNECTED FROM
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM FACING
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS. THEY
SOMETIMES NEED A LITTLE BIT OF
EXTRA SUPPORT TO GET INTO THAT
APPRENTICESHIP, GET INTO THAT
JOB, SO THERE ARE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
THROUGH THE GRANT PROGRAM WE
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE HAD A PAID TRAINING
BECAUSE AGAIN OPPORTUNITY YOUTH
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO NOT BE
EARNING. BUT MAYBE THEY NEED
THAT EXTRA HELP. SO FOR THE PRE
APPRENTICES WE HOPE THAT THEY
MATRICULATE INTO THE WHOLE
SYSTEM OF APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE BUILDING AND
THAT LINKAGE IS ONE OF THE KEY
THINGS THAT WE ALSO LOOKED AT IN
EVALUATING THE GRANTS AND WITH
RESPECT TO OUR, OUR, OUR BUDGET,
ONE OF OUR PROBLEMS IS WE'RE NOT
COLLECTING ENOUGH REVENUE Dð TO
MEET WHAT WE WANT TO SPEND AND
ONE OF THE REVENUE SOURCES IS
INCOME TAXES FROM PEOPLE THAT
ARE EMPLOYED. AND SO SPENDING
THIS MONEY, I WOULD THINK, WOULD
CREATE THAT. ON THE OTHER END, A
CUT TO THIS EXACERBATES THE
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE ALREADY
HAVING, WHICH IS WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY ON THE REVENUE SIDE
FROM PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING. SO
WE HAVE TO GROW THE ECONOMY. AND
IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S WHAT THIS
DOES. SO YOU SPEND MONEY HERE,
BUT WE MAKE A LOT MORE MONEY ON
THE OTHER SIDE. YES, I AGREE
WITH THE PHILOSOPHY THERE. ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. ISSUE NUMBER TWO, WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION UNIT. AGAIN, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE ANDREW MARCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. CHAZ
ALAMO LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE
ADELE BURNS, DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS, ISSUE
NUMBER TWO, COVERS THE WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION UNIT AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS, DIR. FIRST, WE WILL
HEAR FROM ANDREW MARCH. ANDREW
MARCH, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE 2022 BUDGET INCLUDED $15
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONGOING FOR
THE WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION
PRIORITY UNIT, THIS PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TO REDUCE THAT TO $10 MILLION
ONGOING, WHICH, I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST REFRAME IT THAT THE $15
MILLION WAS PROVIDED AT A VERY
DIFFERENT TIME WITH A VERY
DIFFERENT BUDGET OUTLOOK, A
LARGE SURPLUS. SO THIS REDUCTION
SORT OF WE FEEL RIGHT SIZES THE
INVESTMENT WHILE MAINTAINING THE
COMMITMENT TO THE WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION PRIORITY UNIT OF
MAINTAINING THE ONGOING FUNDING.
THANK YOU. ALLOW NO SPECIFIC
COMMENTS ON ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. DIR ALL RIGHT.
SO WITH THE WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION UNIT, WE HAVE
ROLLED OUT THE FIRST ROUND OF
THE EQUAL REPRESENTATION IN
CONSTRUCTION APPRENTICESHIP
GRANTS. ERICA, FOR SHORT, WITH
THE FIRST 25 MILLION ENCUMBERED
AND GOING TO 19 DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE TWO
CATEGORIES OF FUNDING IN THE
GRANT, WHICH INCLUDE SUPPORTIVE
RESOURCES FOR CHILDCARE AND
OUTREACH AND COMMUNITY BUILDING
TO TRY TO INVITE MORE
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS INTO THE
BUILDING TRADES. AND WE HAVE THE
FIRST TWO REPORTING PERIODS
COMPLETE, SO WE HAVE SOME
INITIAL IMPACT METRICS TO SHARE
WITH YOU TODAY, SO THE OVERALL
TARGET NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS
THAT WE'RE AIMING TO SERVE, WITH
THE SUPPORT OF RESOURCES FOR
CHILDCARE SPECIFICALLY, IS 2153
PARTICIPANTS. SO THAT'S THE
OVERALL PLAN OVER THE LIFE OF
THE GRANT, WHICH WERE SORT OF A
THIRD OF THE WAY INTO, BUT
REALLY WE ONLY HAVE THE FIRST
TWO REPORTING PERIODS. SO ACTUAL
PARTICIPANTS SERVED IN THOSE
FIRST TWO PERIODS IS ONLY 77,
WHICH IS NOT THAT SURPRISING
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE GRANTEES
ARE SETTING UP THEIR SYSTEMS FOR
REIMBURSED OR STIPEND OF CHILD
CARE. SO WE'RE EXPECTING THOSE
NUMBERS TO GO UP. BUT WE
CERTAINLY LOOKED AT THE FIRST
SET OF PARTICIPANTS. AND OF
THOSE ACTUAL PARTICIPANTS, 31%
ARE WOMEN, AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT THIS CHILDCARE
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE TO ALL
APPRENTICES AND PRE APPRENTICES,
PARENTS AND LEGAL GUARDIANS WHO
ARE IN BUILDING TRADES,
APPRENTICESHIP A BUILDING TRADES
PROGRAMS THAT GOT THIS GRANT.
WHILE OF COURSE IT WOULD BE NICE
IF THE GENDER BREAKDOWN WAS
CLOSER TO 50, IT IS IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT IN 2023, 3.95%
OF BUILDING TRADES APPRENTICES
ARE WERE WOMEN. SO BY
COMPARISON, 31% IS ACTUALLY A
PRETTY SOLID NUMBER. AND I THINK
IF WE ALL GOT TO THE END OF THIS
PROJECT AND THERE WERE 31% WOMEN
IN THE BUILDING TRADES, I THINK
WE WOULD ALL BE PRETTY EXCITED,
SO WE OF COURSE ALSO WANT TO
ZOOM OUT AND LOOK AT THE OVERALL
REPRESENTATION NUMBERS IN
APPRENTICESHIP AS A WHOLE, NOT
JUST IN THIS SET THAT GOT THE
GRANT, SO IN 2022, THERE WERE
3.73% OF NEW CÁC APPRENTICES
WERE WOMEN. AND IN 2023, WE SAW
THAT TICK UP A LITTLE BIT TO
3.95. SO THAT IS AN IMPROVEMENT.
BUT THIS IS THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
BUT OF COURSE WE WANT TO BE
SEEING MORE SIGNIFICANT GAINS IN
THE COMING YEARS WITH THIS
INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE REALLY
JUST EMBARKING ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF, SO WITHIN DIR
AND DÍAS, WE ARE IMPLEMENTING
THE ONE YEAR REVIEW OF THE ERICA
GRANTEES COMING UP IN JUNE AND
JULY, WE HAVE BEEN CONVENING THE
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION COMMITTEE,
WHICH HAS MET QUARTERLY SINCE Q2
OF 2023, AND THAT GROUP'S BEEN
LOOKING AT LIKE A LITERATURE
REVIEW OF, OF HOW HAS THIS ISSUE
BEEN EVALUATED, DOING A DATA
DIVE INTO REPRESENTATION IN THE
DIFFERENT TRADES WITHIN THE
BUILDING TRADES AND ALSO WORKING
TO DEVELOP A WORK PLAN FOR THE
GROUP WITH ACTIVITIES AND GOALS.
SO THAT IS UNDERWAY, AND WE ARE
ALSO DOING A OUTREACH AND
MARKETING CAMPAIGN WITH THE
SUPPORT OF CONTRACTING AND
MARKETING FIRM AND WORKING WITH
THE DIR OFFICE OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS TO DO REALLY AN
AMPLIFICATION OF THE MESSAGES OF
ALL OF THE OUTREACH EFFORTS OF
THE ERICA GRANTEES. AND WE ARE
ALSO IN THE MIDST OF HIRING A
FEW FOLKS WITHIN DIR TO SUPPORT
WITH THIS, AND SPECIFICALLY, WE
BROUGHT ON AN APPRENTICESHIP
CONSULTANT. SHE'S AMAZING NAMED
LIZETTE CRUZ, WHO'S OUR EQUITY
AND INCLUSION APPRENTICESHIP
CONSULTANT AND LEADING THE WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION WORK WITHIN DÍAS
AND WITH THE ERICA GRANTEES, AND
WE'RE ALSO IN FINAL INTERVIEW
STAGES FOR A PERSON IN OUR
FUNDING TEAM. SO NEXT STEPS, WE
CONTINUE TO CULTIVATE THIS
COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE OF THE
ERICA GRANTEES SO THAT THEY CAN
BE SHARING EFFECTIVE PRACTICES
ACROSS THEM, WE ARE PLANNING TO
RUN ANOTHER ROUND OF THE ERICA
GRANTS IN LATER IN THIS CALENDAR
YEAR. AND WE WILL DO SO WITH THE
FUNDS MADE AVAILABLE TO US FOR
THAT EFFORT, AND OF COURSE,
WE'RE WE'RE CONTINUING WITH THAT
MARKETING CAMPAIGN AGAIN TO
AMPLIFY THE OUTREACH EFFORTS
THAT ARE TAKING PLACE WITH THE
ERICA OUTREACH AND COMMUNITY
BUILDING GRANTEES. I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS, DO WE, SENATOR,
SAY, SORRY. ALSO, YES. I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY. THIS IS A
PERMANENT CUT THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED. AND YES, IT'S A
PERMANENT REDUCTION, REDUCING
THE 15 MILLION ONGOING TO 10
MILLION ONGOING. GIVEN THE
PROJECTED BUDGET DEFICIT IN THE
OUT YEARS, WE FEEL THAT THIS IS
A PRUDENT MEASURE TO TAKE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT IT WASN'T ALL
CUT, BUT IT'S SUCH A SMALL
AMOUNT TO BEGIN WITH. I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT IT BEING AN
ONGOING CUT, WOMEN HOLD THE
MAJORITY OF LOW WAGE JOBS IN
THIS COUNTRY, AND IT'S A DIRECT
REASON ON WHY THERE IS A
PERSISTENT GENDER WAGE GAP. AND
SO IF WE DON'T ADDRESS THE
OPPORTUNITY REYES AND REALLY
INVEST IN WOMEN, FOR THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET HIGHER PAID
JOBS, WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO BE
WE'RE ALWAYS EVERY YEAR WE'RE
GOING TO CELEBRATE OR NOT
CELEBRATE THE FACT THAT, THIS
GENDER GAP IS SO PERSISTENT. SO
SEEING AS HOW IT IS SHOWING,
VERY POSITIVE SIGNS OF SUCCESS,
I JUST WOULD, WOULD ASK WHY,
ESPECIALLY SUCH A SMALL AMOUNT
WOULD BE PERMANENTLY REDUCED.
AND CONSIDERING THE IMPACT THE
ENORMOUS IMPACT FOR SUCH A SMALL
AMOUNT WOULD HAVE ON HELPING
WOMEN GET INTO HIGHER PAID JOBS.
YES, ACROSS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, THERE ARE MANY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS THAT HAD TO BE MADE,
AND SO WE HAD TO REEVALUATE OUR
ONGOING COMMITMENTS AS WELL, TO
BE ABLE TO, TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
OTHER COMMITMENTS THAT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE MADE OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS, SO, YOU KNOW, AS
YOU NOTED, RATHER THAN REDUCING
THE ENTIRE AMOUNT, WE FEEL THAT
REDUCING IT TO $10 MILLION STILL
PROVIDES A MEANINGFUL IMPACT TO
THIS COMMUNITY, WHILE
MAINTAINING THE ONGOING FUNDING.
ARE YOU DONE, SENATOR SERRATO, A
LITTLE BIT ON THE SAME LINES. SO
DOES THIS REDUCTION REFLECT A
NONUSE OF THE $5 MILLION? AND SO
IT'S SITTING ON THE SHELF, AND
NOT BECAUSE THERE ISN'T ENOUGH
PARTICIPATION OR IS IT AN ACTUAL
CUT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE
SERVING THAT MUCH LESS PEOPLE IN
THIS IN THE, IN THE PROGRAM. SO
THE $15 MILLION IS, IS COULD BE
USED VERY BROADLY BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. SO IN ADDITION TO
FUNDING STAFF AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION COMMITTEE,
IT CAN BE ALSO USED FOR SUPPORT.
SO IT'S DEPENDING UP TO THE
DEPARTMENT SORT OF HOW MUCH IS
USED FOR THESE VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES. SO TO DATE, THE
MAJORITY OF THE FUNDING HAS BEEN
USED TO PROVIDE GRANTS. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
NOTED, BUT IN THE FUTURE IT
COULD BE USED FOR DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES. I'M TRYING TO
QUANTIFY HOW MUCH THAT $5
MILLION CUT, RESULTS IN AS FAR
AS INCOME LATER ON TO THE STATE.
IN OTHER WORDS, ARE WE ARE WE
GIVING UP $20 MILLION OF
INCREASED ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FOR
A $5 MILLION CUT A YEAR? WE
DON'T DOING THAT. I'D RATHER
SPEND THE FIVE AND TAKE THE 20
LATER ON. UNDERSTOOD. WE DON'T
DO THOSE SORTS OF PROJECTIONS.
BUT THIS THIS PROGRAM IS DONE TO
REIMBURSE FOR CHILD CARE IS WHAT
THE GRANTS HAVE BEEN DONE. SO
FOR, PREDOMINANT UP TO THE
STATE. SO IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
SIMILAR TO THE OTHER PROGRAM,
THE YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
THAT WAS NOTED EARLIER. SO IT
ENABLES THEM TO GET THE TRAINING
THEY NEED TO GET GET INTO THE
ECONOMY AND, AND RETURN, MAKE
GREAT RETURNS. SO THAT'S WHAT
I'M KIND OF GETTING AT. THERE'S
SOME MONEY WE SPEND IN THE FRONT
TO MAKE MORE IN THE BACK, AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS OUR MONEY
ON HIGH VISIBILITY, BUT WHAT?
BUT NOT PAY ATTENTION TO WHAT
IT'S CREATING ON THE OTHER SIDE,
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THE
PROBLEM WE'RE HAVING WITH OUR
BUDGET, WHICH IS NOT ENOUGH
REVENUE FROM PEOPLE WITH
MEANINGFUL JOBS THAT PAY WELL,
THAT ENABLE THEM TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE ECONOMY. THANK YOU. MISS.
ONE MORE COMMENT, SENATOR
DURAZZO, IF I WOULD ASK YOU TO
LOOK AT SETTING ASIDE A
PERCENTAGE OF THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SO THAT WE
HAVE AN ONGOING WE DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT BEING CUT, JUST
RESERVE A PERCENTAGE FROM THAT
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND APPRENTICESHIPS.
THANK YOU, I PERSONALLY JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT THERE ARE WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION IN MY DISTRICT,
AND I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM, AND I'D BE MORE INTERESTED
IN A LITTLE BIT OF THE
DEMOGRAPHICS, PARTICULARLY WOMEN
WHO, YOU KNOW, LET'S SAY ARE OF
CHILD REARING, BEARING AGE, IF
THEY ARE PREGNANT, OBVIOUSLY THE
WORK IS A LITTLE BIT, YOU KNOW,
ACCOMMODATIONS HAVE TO BE MADE
NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO, AFTER
THEY HAVE A CHILD AND SOME OF
THEM HAVE SHARED WITH ME STORIES
OF, FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN THEY HAVE
C-SECTIONS AND SO FORTH, THEY
CANNOT LIFT 50 POUNDS, RIGHT?
THEY CANNOT DO SOME OF THE
PHYSICAL WORK THAT IS REQUIRED
IN CONSTRUCTION. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE PROGRAMS OR
ARRANGEMENTS MADE TO ENTICE
WOMEN OF ALL AGES TO BE ABLE TO
DO CONSTRUCTION WORK. THIS IS
ALSO INCLUDING LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS IN CONSTRUCTION, NOT
JUST THE PHYSICAL LABOR PIECE OF
IT AND THE PLANNING AND
MANAGEMENT AND SO FORTH OF
DIFFERENT PROJECTS, I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE A FULL PIPELINE FOR WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION, AND
CONSTRUCTION IS NOT OBVIOUSLY
JUST, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, MANY
OF US SOMETIMES THINK, YOU KNOW,
JUST CONSTRUCTION IS LIKE, LET'S
SAY, CARPENTRY AND LIKE PUTTING
UP, YOU KNOW, WALLS AND SO FORTH
. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
WORK THAT IS SUBDIVIDED INTO
CONSTRUCTION, YOU KNOW,
ELECTRICAL. AND SO FORTH. THAT
CAN BE VERY MUCH, A GREAT JOB
FOR WOMEN. AND IT'S ESPECIALLY
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS, UNION JOBS,
AND SO, SO MUCH MORE. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE BIT MORE
PLANNING AND THEN ALSO A LITTLE
BIT MORE DATA IN REGARDS TO THE
DEMOGRAPHICS, AGE, HOW LONG
THEY'VE BEEN IN IT. BECAUSE IF
THEY ONLY DO IT FOR, YOU KNOW, A
YEAR AND THEN HAVE TO DIP OUT
BECAUSE THEY HAD A BABY OR THEY
CAN'T, YOU KNOW, KEEP UP WITH
THE PHYSICAL DEMANDS AND SO
FORTH. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM. AND IT,
YOU KNOW, PROGRAMS AND
ARRANGEMENTS DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY TO ATTRACT AND
MAINTAIN WOMEN, INCLUDING THOSE
THAT ARE, AGING AS WELL, YOU
KNOW, PAST 45, 50, 60, SO FORTH,
SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF THAT. AND I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION.
I'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE, VARIOUS
GOVERNORS PROPOSALS FOR DER.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM ANDREW
MARCH, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COURTNEY MASSENGALE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. CHAZ ALAMO
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
JOSH IVERSON, CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER OF DER SEBASTIAN
SANCHEZ, DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
AGRICULTURAL, AGRICULTURE AND
IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE, LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
VICTORIA HASSID, ALB BOARD CHAIR
DEANNA PING, CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF DER JULIA
MONTGOMERY, NLRB GENERAL COUNSEL
, DOES A LOT OF PEOPLE, ISSUE
NUMBER THREE COVERS VARIOUS
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR DER.
FIRST, WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ANDREW MARCH, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ANDREW MARCH,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO AS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA, THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMITTEE WANTS TO FOCUS ON THE
RURAL STRATEGIC ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAM, SO I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUES TO PROVIDE MORE
CONTEXT ON THAT. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DEANNA PING.
I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED, ITEM THREE LISTS
SEVERAL BCP'S FOR DISCUSSION,
BUT WILL MOSTLY FOCUS ON THE
RURAL STRATEGIC ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAM. BUT I DID JUST WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
COMMON THEME ACROSS OUR
PROPOSALS. AND IN SHORT, THEY
SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
OUR SERVICE DELIVERY, INCREASE
DEPARTMENTAL CAPACITY, AND SCALE
OUR IMPACT THROUGH AUTOMATION
PROJECTS TO MODERNIZE OUR
SYSTEMS SO THAT WE CAN BETTER
SUPPORT ENFORCEMENT, DATA
ANALYSIS AND OUR ADJUDICATION
EFFORTS. IT ALSO SUPPORTS OUR
STAFFING AUGMENTATIONS TO
ADDRESS INCREASING WORKLOAD
DEMANDS, AND AS WELL AS OUTREACH
RESOURCES TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
REACH AND ENGAGE VULNERABLE
WORKERS. AND SO WITH THAT, I'M
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
SEBASTIAN SANCHEZ, OUR DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF AGRICULTURE AND
IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE, TO TALK
ABOUT THE RURAL ENGAGEMENT, BCP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
THIS, RURAL STRATEGIC ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAM, WAS DEVELOPED AT THE
INSTRUCTION OF SECRETARY KNOX,
IN CONJUNCTION WITH BOTH THE
ALRB AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS, THIS
PROGRAM IS MEANT TO ADDRESS
ONGOING GAPS IN OUR ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY SERVICE WORKERS IN
RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE,
CONSISTENTLY AND THROUGH OUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH, STAKEHOLDERS,
AS WELL AS THROUGH OUR ONGOING
OUTREACH PROGRAMS, THE COVID 19
WORKPLACE OUTREACH PROJECT, AND
THE STATEWIDE AGRICULTURE AND
FARMWORKER EDUCATION PROGRAM.
WE'VE CONTINUED TO HEAR THAT
THERE ARE PARTICULAR CHALLENGES
FOR FARM WORKERS AND WORKERS IN
RURAL AREAS. THERE'S A LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE AS TO WHERE THEY
SHOULD GO AND WHO THEY SHOULD
ENGAGE, NOT REALLY PROPERLY
UNDERSTANDING WHICH OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DO WHAT, WE
ALSO HAVE ONGOING SILOED
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS. THERE'S
BEEN AN EFFORT TO INCREASE THE
COLLABORATION, BUT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BREAK DOWN THOSE
SILOS AND ENCOURAGE MORE
COLLABORATION ACROSS ALL OUR
AGENCIES, AND LEVERAGE ALL OF
THE STAFF THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE
IN BOTH OUTREACH AND ENFORCEMENT
TO WORK TOGETHER, AND WE ALSO
JUST WANT TO REDUCE THE
OBSTACLES WITH REGARDS TO
DISTANCE THAT FARM WORKERS HAVE
IN ENGAGING OUR OFFICES, WE HAVE
THREE PRIORITIES FOR THIS
PROGRAM. ONE IS INCREASING
ACCESS TO IN-PERSON SERVICES AND
CREATING ONE STOP LOCATIONS
WHERE A FARM WORKER CAN COME, OR
A RURAL WORKER CAN COME AND
ADDRESS ANY QUESTION THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE, WHETHER IT'S A WAGE
AND HOUR QUESTION, A HEALTH AND
SAFETY QUESTION, OR A QUESTION
ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN
COLLECTIVE ACTION IN THE
WORKPLACE, WE PLAN TO DO THAT
THROUGH ONGOING CLINICS,
LAUNCHING CLINICS IN
COLLABORATION WITH TRUSTED
PARTNERS THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THROUGH OUR
CO-OP PROGRAMS, WHERE WE WILL
BRING ALL OF OUR AGENCIES,
INCLUDING EVEN WORKING WITH ED
TO BRING UI SERVICES AND DEI
SERVICES TO FARM WORKERS, THE
SECOND PART OF THIS IS REALLY
ESTABLISHING A NO WRONG DOOR
POLICY AND CROSS TRAINING ALL
OUR STAFF TO HAVE A MINIMUM
LEVEL OF KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING AS TO WHAT RIGHTS
AND PROTECTIONS FARM WORKERS
HAVE IN THE WORKPLACE, AS WELL
AS EMPLOYER OBLIGATIONS, SO THAT
IF A FARM WORKER ENGAGES ANY OF
OUR ENTITIES, RATHER THAN BEING
TOLD, HERE'S A PHONE NUMBER,
HERE'S A WEBSITE, THEY WILL BE
WARMLY HANDED OFF TO THE
APPROPRIATE AGENCY THAT HAS
JURISDICTION OVER THE PARTICULAR
ISSUE THAT FARM WORKER HAS, AND
FINALLY, WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
FARM WORKER SPECIFIC, OUTREACH
ASSETS, WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS, PARTICULARLY
THROUGH OUR COVID EFFORTS, THAT
WE NEED TO DEVELOP MORE AUDIO
VISUAL TOOLS FOR FARM WORKERS,
AND REALLY SIMPLE, PLAIN
LANGUAGE ITEMS. SO THAT WILL BE
THE FOCUS OF OUR WORK, I'LL PASS
IT ALONG TO JULIE MONTGOMERY,
OUR GENERAL COUNSEL FOR LRB, TO
GO INTO A LITTLE MORE DETAIL AS
TO LRB'S ROLE. IT'S ON. OKAY.
THANK YOU. YES. SO THE ALRB WILL
BE IMPLEMENTING, THE PARTS OF
THE PROPOSAL THAT THAT SEBASTIAN
MENTIONED, SPECIFICALLY RELATING
TO, CROSS TRAINING AND, AND,
PROVIDING, PROVIDING CONTENT
FOR, FOR THAT TRAINING AND
COLLABORATING WITH THE DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN OUR LABOR AGENCY SO THAT
WE CAN BREAK DOWN SILOS, AS HE
MENTIONED, AND PROVIDE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT ONE ANOTHER DOES
, AND ALSO JUST MAKE SURE
EVERYONE HAS SOME MINIMAL TOOLS
IN PLACE, CULTURAL COMPETENCY.
UNDERSTAND HOW TO WORK WITH FARM
WORKERS, HOW TO REFER CASES TO
ONE ANOTHER, HOW TO WORK
TOGETHER MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
JUST INCREASE ACCESS TO THE
STATE SO THAT FARM WORKERS CAN
COME TO ANY OF OUR OFFICES OR
ANY LOCATIONS AND GET SERVICES.
WE WILL ALSO BE STRATEGICALLY
PLACING STAFF IN RURAL LOCATIONS
THAT ARE HARDER TO ACCESS FOR
FARM WORKERS, SO THAT THEY CAN
GET, MORE, MORE FACE TIME, MORE,
MORE SERVICES FROM FROM OUR
STAFF AND REPRESENTATIVES WILL
BE WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH
NONPROFIT, COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL TO FURTHER
VÀ, THOSE SERVICES AND REDUCE
BARRIERS. AND AS SEBASTIAN
MENTIONED, WE ARE ALSO GOING TO
BE SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDING OUR,
OUR, OUR OUTREACH ASSETS. WE
ALREADY DID, WE HAD A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL, APPROVED THREE
YEARS AGO, IN WHICH WE HIRED
FOUR OUTREACH STAFF PERSONS. ONE
OF THEM WAS JUST HIRED IN THE
LAST YEAR, AND THE OTHER THREE
WERE HIRED A FEW YEARS AGO. BUT
THEY HAVE, GREATLY INCREASED OUR
OUR OUTREACH PRESENCE. AND WE'VE
GOTTEN A START ON OUR OUTREACH
ASSETS AND WE'VE, BEGUN TO
DEVELOP MATERIALS IN, DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES, DIFFERENT FORMATS,
SUCH AS SOCIAL MEDIA CONTENT,
PLAIN LANGUAGE MATERIALS THAT
ARE MORE ACCESSIBLE TO FARM
WORKERS. BUT WE'VE JUST STARTED
THAT PROCESS AND WE NEED TO
GREATLY EXPAND IT. THERE ARE
MANY DIFFERENT INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY THE MORE
THAN 800,000 FARM WORKERS IN
MULTIPLE AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I MEAN, FARM WORKERS ARE
FAR FLUNG ALL OVER THE STATE,
AND, AND THERE'S QUITE A LOT OF
DIVERSITY. SO, SO WE REALLY HAVE
OUR WORK CUT OUT FOR US, AND WE
JUST BARELY BEGUN. SO THIS IS A
MONUMENTAL EFFORT TO BE ABLE TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION. AND IT IS
GOING TO REQUIRE A FAIR AMOUNT
OF RESOURCE AND, AND WORK TO BE
ABLE TO, TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY DELIVER SERVICES TO
THIS POPULATION THAT IS, YOU
KNOW, SPEAKS MANY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES, HAS A LOT OF FEAR
ABOUT BEING RETALIATED AGAINST
AND EVEN COMING FORWARD,
ENFORCING THEIR RIGHTS, TRUSTING
GOVERNMENT TO BEGIN WITH. THESE
ARE ALL VERY DIFFICULT TASKS
THAT WE HAVE TO OVERCOME, AND
THROUGH THROUGH MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO BE ABLE
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO THIS
POPULATION. AND AS WE'VE SEEN,
IT'S THERE'S A GREAT, GREAT NEED
, SO WITH THAT, I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, SENATOR NEWMAN, YEAH.
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION. A QUESTION. HOW
HOW DO WE MEASURE OR TRACK
SUCCESS IN PROGRAMS LIKE THE
RURAL STRATEGIC ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAM? THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION, THERE'S BOTH AN ASPECT
OF LOOKING AT AT THE METRICS, AT
HOW MANY WORKERS THAT WE WILL BE
ENGAGING. AND WE'RE LOOKING IN
THESE MONTHLY CLINICS, AT THE
VERY LEAST, WE PLAN TO LAUNCH AT
LEAST SIX CLINICS BY THE END OF
THIS PROGRAM, THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE LAUNCHED A
SIMILAR CLINIC THAT HAS REALLY
LAID THE FOUNDATION FOR THIS
PROGRAM IN SANTA MARIA. THE
FIRST CLINIC, THEY HAD EIGHT
WORKERS AT THE LAST CLINIC IN
DECEMBER OF THIS PAST YEAR. THEY
HAD OVER 100 WORKERS ATTEND. SO
WE'RE HOPING THAT AT THE VERY
LEAST, WE'LL BE HAVING ONCE WE
START CLINICS, ABOUT 20 TO 30
WORKERS. AND THEN AS WE PROGRESS
AND DEVELOP TRUST IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT WE'RE THERE,
PRESENT REGULARLY, THAT WE'LL BE
SEEING MORE LIKE 40 TO 50
WORKERS PER CLINIC, AND DOING AT
LEAST SIX CLINICS ON A MONTHLY
BASIS, WE'RE ALSO CURRENTLY,
TAKING SOME LESSONS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THE COVID 19
WORKPLACE OUTREACH PROJECT.
WE'RE WORKING IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE POSSIBILITY LAB TO
REALLY DEVELOP AN EVALUATION OF
HOW THIS, OUTREACH PROGRAMS
FUNCTION AND WHAT THE IMPACT IS,
SO WE HAVE INCLUDED IN THIS BCP
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO ENGAGE
WITH VENDORS TO HELP US DEVELOP
AN EVALUATION TO LOOK AT OTHER
METRICS OF HOW THIS PROGRAM CAN
IMPACT FARM WORKERS. SO, SO DO I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE
DEVELOPING A POST CLINIC
EVALUATION METHODOLOGY, BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE ONE IN PLACE YET? IS
THAT CORRECT? HOW DO WE TRACK,
YOU KNOW, THE IMPACT ON
PARTICIPANTS AFTER THE CLINICS?
WELL, WE'RE WE'LL TRACK THE
NUMBER OF WORKERS THAT ARE
ATTENDING THESE CLINICS, KNOW
THE IMPACT ON THEM, POST CLINIC,
WHAT THEY GET OUT OF THE CLINIC.
I THINK THAT WILL WILL BE
DEVELOPING, THAT WILL BE
DEVELOPING. THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT WE'RE PILOTING AND WE'VE
SEEN, THIS HAS BEEN BUILT ON
CARAVANS THAT WE DID THROUGH THE
SWAP PROGRAM, AND WE GOT A LOT
OF FEEDBACK FROM STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT THE NEED TO HAVE REGULAR
PRESENCE. SO WE'RE HOPING TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THAT
INFORMATION WE'VE GOTTEN FROM
STAKEHOLDERS. AND YOU'LL PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION TO US. I ASSUME
OVER TIME. ABSOLUTELY. THANK
YOU. SENATOR DURAZZO, YEAH, I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, YOU MENTIONED 800,000 FARM
WORKERS, BUT, YOU'RE NOT REALLY.
IT'S ACTUALLY VERY, VERY
SHAMEFUL THAT A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA, THAT DEPENDS SO MUCH
ON AGRICULTURE AND THESE 800,000
WORKERS WOULD WHERE THESE
WORKERS WOULD NOT WOULD HAVE THE
CONDITIONS THAT THEY HAVE BOTH
WORKING AND LIVING CONDITIONS
AND THE FEAR THAT THEY LIVE IN.
SO PART OF MY QUESTION IS, I
ASSUME, HAVING EXPERIENCE IN LOW
WAGE INDUSTRIES, THAT WORKING
WITH PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY
IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF THIS,
COULD YOU JUST TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT? ABSOLUTELY, SO AS
I'VE MENTIONED A COUPLE OF
TIMES, THIS THE CLINIC MODEL OF
THIS PROGRAM IS BASED ON LESSONS
WE LEARNED THROUGH OUR COVID 19
WORKPLACE OUTREACH PROJECT,
WHERE WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
TRUSTED MESSENGER AND
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE, DURING THE THAT CAMPAIGN,
WE LAUNCHED THESE CARAVANS THAT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONERS, CAME UP
WITH. AND THEN WE HAD ALL OUR
TEAMS JOIN IN WHERE WE WORKED
WITH AN ORGANIZATION IN A LOCAL
RURAL COMMUNITY TO HELP US DRIVE
THROUGH THE FIELDS, GO TO PLACES
WHERE FARMWORKERS CONGREGATE AND
LIVE, AND BE ABLE TO ENGAGE THE
WORKERS IN THOSE SPACES. THIS
MODEL CONTINUES THAT AND BUILDS
ON THAT BY WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
A TRUSTED PARTNER ORGANIZATION
TO CO-HOST THE CLINIC TO HELP US
DO OUTREACH TO WORKERS, TO HELP
US ENSURE THAT THE WORKERS WILL
BE PRESENT AND MAKE IT A
WELCOMING SPACE FOR, FOR THOSE
WORKERS, WE'RE ALSO LOOKING, I
THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT CROSS
TRAINING OUR STAFF, IT'S NOT
JUST SUBSTANTIVE ISSUES THAT WE
WANT TO TRAIN THEM ON. WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
CULTURAL COMPETENCY TO ENGAGE
WORKERS. SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT, YOU KNOW, ORGANIZATIONS
CAN REALLY HELP PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO US WHEN IF THEY
NEED TO WORK WITH AN
INTERPRETER. FOR EXAMPLE, FOR AN
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE SPEAKER,
THAT'S SOMEWHERE WHERE WE CAN
ALSO WORK WITH TRUSTED PARTNERS.
SO THIS THIS PROGRAM WAS REALLY
MEANT TO BUILD ON OUR EXPERIENCE
THAT WE'VE HAD OVER THE PAST
THREE, THREE YEARS IN DEVELOPING
THESE OUTREACH MODELS WITH WITH
TRUSTED ORGANIZATIONS. AND I
WOULD ALSO JUST ADD THAT IN
ADDITION TO SO MUCH OF THE
GROUNDWORK HAS BEEN LAID IN
THOSE COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
WHERE EVEN AS PART OF SWAP,
WE'VE PUT TOGETHER A WORKING
GROUP TO GET FEEDBACK ON OUR
MATERIALS AT DER. WHAT'S
MISSING, WHAT INFORMATION DO WE
NEED TO ADD? HOW CAN WE SIMPLIFY
THEM? MUCH OF WHICH, INFLUENCED
THE PROPOSAL HERE, RIGHT. BUT IS
ALSO GOING TO BUILD UPON THIS
WORK OF HOW DO WE BETTER TAILOR
THOSE RESOURCES? AND IN MY MIND
TO THAT'S THE WAY WE MEASURE
SUCCESS. I REMEMBER WHEN WE
LAUNCHED THE CARAVANS, IT WAS A
MAD RUSH TO GET AUDIO KHÓ IN
MIXTECO AND TRICKY AND, AND WE
HAD THOSE AND IT WAS GREAT. AND
THE HOPE IS WE CAN MEASURE
SUCCESS BY HAVING MORE OF THOSE
AND HAVING THOSE RESOURCES. AND
WE CAN SEE HOW THEY'RE BEING
UTILIZED BOTH IN THE FIELD AND
ALSO JUST THROUGH KIND OF THE
METRICS ON OUR WEBSITE AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT AS WELL.
THOSE ARE. YES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SIERRA. THANK YOU.
SO WITH THIS PROGRAM, IT'S GOING
TO GENERATE MORE WORKLOAD. AND
FOR THE AGENCIES THAT ARE GOING
TO HANDLE THE COMPLAINTS AND
ALSO PROCESS THOSE COMPLAINTS,
DO YOU GUYS ANTICIPATE HOW MUCH
IT'S GOING TO COST DOWN AND HAVE
YOU DO YOU ARE WE GOING TO HAVE
A BUDGET THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD,
OR ARE YOU GUYS EQUIPPED ALREADY
WITH WITH THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
YOU NEED TO HANDLE THIS
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD DOWNSTREAM?
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
WE'VE BEEN MONITORING OUR
CASELOADS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO. SO WE JUST ARE MONITORING
OUR WORKLOAD ACROSS OUR
DEPARTMENT. WHAT I WILL SAY
THOUGH IS, AND I HATE USING
ANECDOTES. SO FORGIVE ME, BUT I
REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE DOING, IN
THE MIDST OF THE COVID OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN, AND WE HAD A WORKER
WHO, BECAUSE OF A FACT SHEET WE
CREATED ON SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK LEAVE, WAS ABLE TO GO TO
THEIR EMPLOYER AND SAY, LOOK, I
SUBMIT PAID SICK LEAVE, LIKE, I
WOULD LIKE THIS. I GOT COVID AND
THAT EMPLOYER GAVE IT TO THEM.
THAT'S NOT A CLAIM TO US, RIGHT?
LIKE SO I WOULD SAY THAT THERE'S
I CAN'T I CAN'T QUITE
HYPOTHESIZE WHAT THAT MEANS.
RIGHT. IN TERMS OF WHAT OUR
CASELOAD, WHAT I CAN SAY IS
WE'LL MONITOR IT LIKE WE
CONTINUE TO DO SO ACROSS OUR
DEPARTMENT. BUT ALSO I THINK
THAT THERE VERY MUCH IS A GAP IN
WHICH THERE ARE JUST PEOPLE WHO
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THESE
PROTECTIONS. AND BOTH ON THE
EMPLOYER SIDE AND ON THE WORKER
SIDE. RIGHT. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT PART. I'M JUST ARE WE
ANTICIPATING THAT THERE WILL BE
AN INCREASED WORKLOAD, WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BUDGET
FOR IN THE FUTURE? WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. SORRY,
SENATOR DURAZZO HAS AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTION. SORRY. I'M
SORRY. I THOUGHT WE WERE JUST,
DOING QUESTIONS ON THE ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM, BUT I HAVE
SOME BROADER QUESTIONS SORT OF
SEGUE OFF OF SENATOR SALADO
ABOUT THE, STAFFING AT THE DER,
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER. SURE.
OKAY. WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
UNDERSTAFFING, THERE'S A,
BACKLOG OF, ISSUES AND
COMPLAINTS OR CLAIMS, I SHOULD
SAY CLAIMS. SO GIVEN THE SEVERE
BACKLOGS, HOW DO YOU SEE YOUR
PLANS FOR INCREASING THE
STAFFING, TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE
THOSE BACKLOGS, ARE YOU
PROPOSING INCREASES IN STAFFING
TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOGS? SO IN
THE CURRENT ONE MORE I'M SORRY.
ONE MORE QUESTION IS, THE
GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED BUDGET CUTS,
ONE OF THEM WOULD BE ELIMINATING
VACANT POSITIONS. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU ARE
CONSIDERING? I HOPE NOT, THANK
YOU. DO YOU WANT TO TAKE THE,
YEAH. SO WITH THE VACANT
POSITION. SO THAT WAS ADOPTED AS
PART OF EARLY ACTION. SO THE
PROPOSAL, THAT THAT THE, THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED LAST WEEK, IS TO
POTENTIALLY, REDUCE DEPARTMENTS
BUDGETS BY UP TO HALF OF THE
AMOUNT OF VACANT POSITIONS. SO
THERE'S STILL A LOT MORE
CONVERSATIONS TO HAPPEN WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS FAR AS HOW THIS
IS IMPLEMENTED, BUT IT WOULD BE
ACROSS AT THE MOMENT. THE
PROPOSAL IS ACROSS ALL STATE
GOVERNMENT. SO WE WOULD
OBVIOUSLY MONITOR HOW THAT WOULD
IMPACT DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S NO, IMPACTS TO
PROGRAMS. AND SO ON THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER SIDE, I DID WANT TO
NOTE, I DO HAVE COLLEAGUES WITH
ME FROM MY LEADERSHIP TEAM, IN
CASE ANYONE WANTS TO ASK MORE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BCP'S WOULD
PUT FORWARD. WE DON'T HAVE A BCP
FOR THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE STAFFING. YOU MAY RECALL
WE DID, IN THE PREVIOUS BUDGET.
AND SO OUR CURRENT PRIORITY IS
TO FILL THOSE VACANCIES. THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO NOW FROM
THE PREVIOUS AUGMENTATION
SPECIFICALLY THAT WE HAD FOR
WAGE CLAIM. SO WE ARE FOCUSED ON
THAT. WE ACTUALLY JUST RECENTLY
LAUNCHED A NATIONWIDE
RECRUITMENT CAMPAIGN THAT'S
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING CAL OSHA.
AND AS WELL AS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE TO GET
MORE PEOPLE, ELIGIBLE ON THE
LIST TO GET MORE PEOPLE. SO WE
HAVE HIRE A LARGER, POOLS FOR
WHEN WE'RE HIRING CANDIDATES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT TO HOPEFULLY
SCALE UP OUR HIRING. SO
CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE A
PROPOSAL FORWARD IN THIS BUDGET,
BUT WE ARE IT'S OUR MAIN
PRIORITY IS TO GET THOSE VACANCY
RATES DOWN. SO THANK YOU. WE'LL
NOW MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ISSUE
AREA. ISSUE AREA NUMBER FOUR,
GENERAL ED UPDATES. AND ED NEXT
ANDREW MARCH. CHAZ ALAMO, NANCY
FARIAS AND RON HUGHES, WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH Ó. AND WE
ALSO HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
AND DETAILS FROM CALEB HALL,
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU AGAIN.
ISSUE AREA NUMBER FOUR COVERS
GENERAL ED UPDATES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ED, NEXT
PROPOSAL. FIRST WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM ANDREW MARCH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD ANDREW MARCH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA, THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS
OF FUNDING FOR ED NEXT. IT'S THE
THIRD YEAR OF THE OF THE IT
PROJECT, WHICH WILL MODERNIZE
ED'S BENEFIT SYSTEM. I'M JOINED
BY THE DIRECTOR OF ED, WHO WILL
PROVIDE A LARGER UPDATE, AND ON
ED NEXT AS WELL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, THANKS FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO JUST
TO PROVIDE A SHORT OVERVIEW OF
THE MODERNIZATION EFFORTS THAT'S
UNDERWAY, ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO ED NEXT. AND THE IT
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHICH IS THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TODAY, I WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
ALMOST 9000 EMPLOYEES AT ED WHO
DO ALL OF THE WORK TO ANSWER THE
PHONES, COLLECT THE TAXES,
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY. I AM
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
DEDICATION TO THE DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. SO AS YOU
ARE AWARE, ED IMPLEMENTS SOME OF
THE STATE'S MOST VITAL PROGRAMS
FOR WORKERS UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE, DISABILITY INSURANCE,
AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE AS WELL AS
FOR EMPLOYERS. WE COLLECT THE
MOST INCOME TAX IN THE NATION,
SECOND ONLY TO THE IRS. AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THIS DEPARTMENT FOR
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS, MY FOCUS
HAS BEEN ON ONE MAJOR INITIATIVE
THAT HAS HAD AND WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE THE MOST IMPACT TO THE
CUSTOMERS. WE SERVE, INCLUDING
OUR EMPLOYEES. AND THAT'S ED
NEXT. ED NEXT IS A TOP TO BOTTOM
MODERNIZATION AND CULTURE EFFORT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND ITS
PROGRAMS. YES IT'S A VERY BIG IT
PROJECT, BUT IT'S ALSO MUCH MORE
THAN THAT. YOU CAN HAVE THE BEST
TECHNOLOGY IN THE WORLD, BUT IF
YOU DO NOT CHANGE THE PROCESSES,
PROCEDURES AND POLICIES, THE
TECHNOLOGY WILL NOT BE HELPFUL.
FOR EXAMPLE, TECHNOLOGY WILL
HELP US GET PAYMENTS FASTER, OUR
PAYMENTS TO CUSTOMERS FASTER.
BUT IF OUR APPLICATION IS NOT IN
PLAIN LANGUAGE OR IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT CLAIMANTS SPEAK,
THERE WILL INEVITABLY BE DELAYS
AND WE WANT TO PREVENT THAT. AS
SUCH, THE BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU TODAY INCLUDES SEVEN
DIFFERENT WORK STREAMS, EACH
INTENDED TO IMPROVE THE CUSTOMER
EMPLOYEE EXPERIENCE. IT ALL
STARTS WITH LISTENING TO OUR
CUSTOMERS. THE EMPLOYEES, THE
LEGISLATURE, THE AUDITOR, THE
LAO CGRTS VENDORS, OTHER STATES,
SOMETIMES EVEN DOF. BASICALLY,
IF YOU HAVE ADVICE, WE WILL TAKE
IT WITH THAT. I JUST WANT TO
TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT
I KNOW THIS COMMITTEE IS
INTERESTED IN TO PROVIDE ONGOING
SUPPORT TO MULTILINGUAL
COMMUNITIES, WE ESTABLISH A
LANGUAGE ACCESS OFFICE LED BY
OUR LANGUAGE ACCESS OFFICER.
THEIR WORK HAS HELPED ESTABLISH
DEDICATED UI CALL CENTERS IN THE
MOST COMMONLY SPOKEN LANGUAGES,
WHILE ALSO PROVIDING ACCESS TO
INTERPRETERS AND OVER 200
LANGUAGES AT NO COST. WE CREATED
A USER EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS A
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE TEAM,
ENSURING OUR CUSTOMERS ARE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF EVERY CHANGE WE
MAKE. WE HAVE USED MANY OF THE
THOUSANDS OF COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS FROM CUSTOMERS AND
STAFF IN OUR MODERNIZATION
EFFORTS. IN JUNE OF 2023, WE
LAUNCHED MY ED, OUR NEW SHARED
CUSTOMER PORTAL. MY ED EMBODIES
OUR APPROACH TO MODERNIZATION,
DELIVERING IMPROVEMENTS TO
CUSTOMERS QUICKLY AND MAKING
MEANINGFUL CHANGES OVER TIME. MY
ED LAUNCHED IN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH, AND AS OF LAST MONTH,
THE PORTAL IS AVAILABLE IN THE
TOP EIGHT LANGUAGES USED BY ED
CUSTOMERS. IN PARALLEL, WE'VE
ALSO MADE OUR UI APPLICATION
AVAILABLE IN THE TOP EIGHT
LANGUAGES, INCLUDING ARMENIAN,
KOREAN, TAGALOG, SPANISH,
SIMPLIFIED CHINESE AND
TRADITIONAL CHINESE, AS WELL AS
VIETNAMESE MOVING FORWARD, WE
ARE ALSO WORKING ON A COMPLETE
OVERHAUL OF OUR UI ONLINE
APPLICATION, SHORTENING THE
APPLICATION BY ELIMINATING
UNNECESSARILY UNNECESSARY OR
DUPLICATIVE QUESTIONS AND
ADOPTING PLAIN LANGUAGE TO MAKE
THE QUESTIONS SIMPLER AND EASIER
TO UNDERSTAND. FOR EXAMPLE,
WE'LL BE CHANGING QUESTIONS FROM
LIKE, ARE YOU READY AND WILLING
TO ACCEPT PART TIME WORK IN YOUR
USUAL TYPE OF WORK? TO A SIMPLE
QUESTION, ARE YOU ABLE TO ACCEPT
A PART TIME JOB? IF LISTENING TO
CUSTOMERS IS THE FIRST STEP,
THEN BETTER COMMUNICATION IS THE
SECOND. WE KNOW THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT INFORMATION THAT
CUSTOMERS WANT IS THE STATUS OF
THEIR CLAIM. AS PART OF OUR
MODERNIZATION, WE'VE CREATED NEW
TEXT MESSAGING SERVICES FOR OUR
UI, FL, AND DI PROGRAMS,
PROVIDING CUSTOMERS WITH
IMPORTANT INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR CLAIMS. WE ALSO LAUNCHED A
UI CLAIM STATUS TRACKER, WHICH
PROVIDES CUSTOMERS WITH REAL
TIME INFORMATION ABOUT THE
STATUS OF THEIR CLAIM. IMMEDIATE
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THEY LOG IN,
WE PLAN TO INTRODUCE A SIMILAR
CLAIM STATUS TRACKER FOR DI AND
FL IN THE IN THE NEXT COMING
MONTHS FOR OUR CALL CENTERS,
WE'VE PARTNERED WITH AMAZON TO
DEVELOP A NEW PLATFORM, WHICH
WILL LAUNCH LATER THIS YEAR.
IT'S THE SAME PLATFORM THAT'S
USED IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS, AND
IT WILL GIVE CUSTOMERS MORE
SELF-SERVICE OPTIONS AND MAKE IT
EASIER FOR OUR STAFF TO PROVIDE
CALLERS WHAT THEY NEED. WE ALSO
PLAN TO LAUNCH A SECURE LIVE
CHAT SERVICE, PROVIDING EVEN
MORE REAL TIME INFORMATION.
WHETHER A CUSTOMER INTERACTS
WITH US ONLINE OR BY PAPER,
PROTECTING THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS A PRIORITY.
DURING THE PANDEMIC, WE BEGAN
USING ID.ME TO VERIFY CLAIMANTS
IDENTITIES IN REAL TIME. ID
ALLOWS CUSTOMERS TO VERIFY THEIR
INFORMATION BY UPLOADING
DOCUMENTS OR CONNECTING WITH A
LIVE AGENT AS PART OF ED. NEXT,
WE PLAN TO FURTHER IMPROVE OUR
IDENTITY VERIFICATION PROCESS BY
ALSO ADOPTING FRICTIONLESS
TECHNOLOGY FROM SECURE. WE
ESTIMATE THAT THIS WILL ALLOW
MOST OF OUR CUSTOMERS TO VERIFY
THEIR IDENTITIES WITHOUT THE
NEED TO UPLOAD DOCUMENTS. LAST,
BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST, IS THE
ADOPTION OF THE NEW TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEM THAT WE'RE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT. THIS EFFORT WILL REPLACE
THE CORE BENEFIT SYSTEMS WE USE
TO PROCESS CLAIMS, WHICH HAVE
NOT BEEN MODERNIZED IN DECADES.
THE REQUEST FOR INFORMATION
PERIOD JUST CLOSED LAST MONTH,
AND THE RESPONSE FROM THE VENDOR
COMMUNITY IS SUPER EXCITING.
EVERYBODY WANTS IN. WE EXPECT
THE NEW SYSTEM WILL ALLOW US TO
MAKE CHANGES TO OUR PROGRAMS
FASTER, IMPROVE SERVICES, AND
BETTER PROVIDE BETTER SUPPORT
FOR OUR EMPLOYEES AND OUR
CUSTOMERS. THAT'S JUST A SHORT
LIST OF SOME OF THE WAYS ED IS
PROVING THE PROCESS, MAKING IT
EASIER FOR CUSTOMERS TO INTERACT
WITH ED. WE'RE COMMITTED,
COMMITTED TO CONTINUALLY IMPROVE
AND APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN FULFILLING
THIS MISSION. I'M JOINED BY MY
AMAZING COLLEAGUES, RON, WHO'S
THE PROJECT DIRECTOR OF ED NEXT,
AND CALEB, WHO IS OUR CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER. THAT'S NOT
CALEB, THAT'S CALEB, TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE JUST ALAMO
WITH THE LAO, NO SPECIFIC
COMMENTS. HAPPY TO PROVIDE
CONTEXT OR ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR SARDO, THANK YOU.
SO THE GOVERNOR IN THE IN THE
BUDGET, THERE'S A $1 BILLION
REPAYMENT FOR TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS THAT WERE MADE PREVIOUSLY
. AND DO WE HAVE A STATUS UPDATE
BECAUSE WE ARE CHALLENGING THAT,
AS FAR AS I REMEMBER, DOES DOES
SEE IF WE COULD GET THAT AMOUNT
LOWERED. SO FOR AS FAR AS FRAUD
GOES, WE'VE COLLECTED ABOUT $6
BILLION. I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH
THE 1 BILLION, BUT Ó THE LOST
WAGES. I SEE THE LOST WAGES. I'M
SORRY. OKAY AND WE HAVE NOT
HEARD BACK FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON THAT. NOT YET. AND
IS THAT AMOUNT INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS A LINE ITEM
FOR POTENTIAL REPAYMENT, OR IS
IF WE DON'T GET THAT, IS IT
GOING TO BE IN ADDITION TO THE
DEFICIT? WE ALREADY HAVE? SO
IT'S INCLUDED IN THE OVERALL
BUDGET. IT'S BEEN OUT. IT'S BEEN
ACCOUNTED FOR. OKAY, OKAY.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS ASKING. SO
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE A SURPRISE
LATER ON WHEN IF THE GOVERNMENT
SAYS NO AND DOESN'T REDUCE THAT
AMOUNT, IT'S ALREADY COVERED IN
THE CURRENT BUDGET. THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU DID. YOU JUMPED RIGHT IN OR
YOU WERE PUSHED IN INTO THIS AND
YOU'VE REALLY TAKEN IT BY THE
HORNS. SO I APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOUR ALL OF YOUR WORK. SO THE UI
SYSTEM BENEFIT SYSTEM, I THINK
YOU WOULD AGREE THAT THE SYSTEM
IS CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED, AND
JUST AS A REMINDER, THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE IS PAID FOR BY THE
WORKERS AS THE DISABILITY,
BENEFITS ARE PAID BY THE
WORKERS, THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS ARE PAID BY EMPLOYERS.
SO IT'S CHRONICALLY UNDER
UNDERFUNDED, WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION DOING TO ADDRESS
THIS? IT'S A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT.
SO WHAT WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION DOING? AND ABOUT
IT. SO AT THIS TIME, THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY PROPOSALS TO
INCREASE TAXES ON EMPLOYERS, AS
TO INCREASE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE TAXES. I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T. THERE IS NO PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO
INCREASE TAXES ON EMPLOYERS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. OKAY
WELL, I WOULD SUGGEST THE I
THINK IT WOULD BE A GREAT THING
TO DO FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE, TO
WORK WITH THE LABOR, TO WORK
WITH EMPLOYERS, TO ADDRESS THIS,
WE'RE PAYING SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
THREE, FOUR, $500 MILLION. JUST
ON THE INTEREST OF, OF, THE LOAN
THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING TO GET.
WHERE ON THE LOWER END OF
CONTRIBUTIONS, WE'RE ON THE
LOWER END OF LOW END OF
BENEFITS. SO I REALLY THINK IT'S
IT I WOULD MAKE THAT SUGGESTION,
TO THE ADMINISTRATION TO WORK
WITH US BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO
COME UP WITH WE'VE GOT TO COME
UP WITH A PATH, TO ADDRESS THIS.
AND ALONG THE LINES OF, THE
TECHNOLOGY, THE NEXT, SPEAKING
OF, OF BENEFITS, THERE ARE SOME
OF US WHO ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO, INCLUDE UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS TO RECEIVE BENEFITS AS
WELL. THEIR EMPLOYERS PAY INTO
THE SYSTEM. BUT THE EMPLOYEES
DON'T GET ANYTHING WHEN THEY'RE
NEEDED. IT'S DIFFICULT TO HOLD
ON TO WORKING PEOPLE WHEN
THERE'S NOT A, A SAFETY NET FOR
THEM WHEN THEY LOSE THEIR JOB
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN,
SO IS THERE ANYTHING IN THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE PROGRAM, THAT
COULD BE INCORPORATED TO, YOU
KNOW, ON THAT PIECE OF IT? I
DON'T MEAN THE POLICY PIECE, BUT
BUT TO ADDRESS THE TECHNOLOGY IS
THAT AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE TO,
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
UNDOCUMENTED? YEAH. FROM FROM A
TECHNOLOGY STANDPOINT, THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY FOR EDD, FOR THE UI
PROGRAM, FOR ALL THE PROGRAMS
WILL BE MUCH MORE FLEXIBLE. THE
PROGRAMS TODAY ARE REALLY
DIFFICULT TO MAKE CHANGES TO
REALLY COSTLY, REALLY TIME
CONSUMING. THE NEW SYSTEMS WILL
BE A LOT MORE FLEXIBLE, SO ANY
PROPOSED PROGRAM CHANGES WILL BE
MUCH EASIER TO IMPLEMENT. AND IS
THIS THE RIGHT TIMING? YOU KNOW,
IN TERMS OF TAKING THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION? YEAH, I MEAN,
ONCE ONCE WE GET THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY IMPLEMENTED. AND BY
THE WAY, WE'VE WE'VE DRAFTED THE
RFP, WE'RE GOING TO RELEASE IT
IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR. THEN ONCE
WE GET THAT IMPLEMENTED, MAKING
CHANGES WILL BE MUCH MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD THAN WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO TODAY. OKAY OKAY. I
THINK THAT'S IT. THANK YOU, I'D
LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION. DOES
EDD, ANTICIPATE STATE SPENDING
ALL OF ITS EDD NEXT 2023 SLASH
2024 APPROPRIATIONS BY JUNE
30TH? YES. SO WE GOT AN EXTENDED
APPROPRIATION PERIOD, TO JUNE
30TH OF 2025. AND SO WE WILL
SPEND ALL THAT, APPROPRIATION BY
THAT POINT, IT WAS IN THE BUDGET
LANGUAGE FOR, I THINK, 2023.
OKAY. SO AS OF TODAY, WHAT IS
THE PROJECTED OVERALL COST FOR
EDD NEXT? I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
PUT MY GLASSES ON. SORRY. IT'S,
IT IS 1.258 BILLION, HASN'T
CHANGED. AND, WE'LL HAVE A
LITTLE MORE CLARITY ONCE WE
COMPLETE THE LAST PROCUREMENT,
WHICH IS THE INTEGRATED CLAIMS
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. BUT WE'RE
VERY COMFORTABLE WITH THE NUMBER
1.25 MILLION, BILLION, SORRY,
BILLION, BILLION. YES OKAY. AND
OVERALL FOR HOW MANY YEARS. WHEN
IS THIS GOING TO BE LIKE FULLY
COMPLETE. IT'S A FIVE YEAR
PROCESS FIVE YEAR PROJECT. AND
THE COMPLETION DATE DEPENDS ON
THE VENDOR SELECTED, WE REACHED
OUT TO THE VENDOR COMMUNITY.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO THEM
CONSTANTLY FOR THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS. AND DEPENDING ON THE
SOLUTION CHOSEN, IT WILL EITHER
BE A THREE YEAR IMPLEMENTATION
OR A FOUR AND A HALF YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION. THÀNH. SO AGAIN,
WE'LL HAVE MORE CLARITY ON THE
TOTAL PROJECT COSTS AND THE
SCHEDULE ONCE WE COMPLETE THE
PROCUREMENT. ALL RIGHT. I
PERSONALLY WANT TO JUST THANK
THE DIRECTOR OF EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT FOR
MEETING WITH ME. ONE ON ONE. I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT. I
KNOW THAT YOU DEEPLY CARE ABOUT
A LOT OF THE WORK. I HAVE A
QUESTION IN REGARDS TO EDD,
AMOUNTS FOR PEOPLE, WHAT IS THE
LOWEST TO THE MAXIMUM THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL CAN MAKE? THE LOWEST,
I BELIEVE, IS $50, AND THE MAX
IS 450 A WEEK A WEEK. AND HOW
LONG HAS IT BEEN SINCE THAT'S
BEEN UPDATED? IT'S PROBABLY
OLDER THAN ME, I DON'T KNOW, AND
I'M OLD. 2000 OKAY. AND CAN A
PERSON SURVIVE ON $50 A WEEK?
MADAM CHAIR, IF I MAY, I
UNDERSTAND THE LINE OF THE
QUESTIONING. WE, AS AN OFFICE
JUST REQUESTED SOME SORT OF
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL DATA FROM THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT ON THE INCOME
CHARACTERISTICS OF PEOPLE WHO
GET UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS. IN STATUTE, THE
MINIMUM IS $50 A WEEK. IN
PRACTICE, ALMOST NO ONE RECEIVES
SUCH A SMALL AMOUNT. VERY FEW
WORKERS RECEIVE A UI BENEFIT
THAT'S LESS THAN $200 A WEEK, SO
STATUTORILY AS A POLICY, THAT IS
OUR STATE'S MINIMUM. BUT IN
PRACTICE, BECAUSE OF THE STATE'S
LABOR MARKET IN 2024, IT'S
DIFFICULT TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR UI
AND BE ELIGIBLE FOR SUCH A SMALL
AMOUNT. SO THE PRACTICAL EFFECT
IS SO, SO PRACTICALLY, ON
AVERAGE, AN INDIVIDUAL WHO'S ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE RECEIVES
ABOUT $800 A MONTH. RIGHT?
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID, $200 A
WEEK, VERY FEW PEOPLE RECEIVING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE RECEIVE
BENEFITS LOWER THAN $200 A WEEK.
THE AVERAGE IS ABOUT $350 A
WEEK. SO MORE LIKE $1,400 A
MONTH. SO $1,400 A MONTH. DOES
THAT COVER RENT? THE AVERAGE
RENT IN CALIFORNIA? I DON'T
KNOW, OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
WHAT THE IT DOESN'T IT PROBABLY
DOESN'T COVER. IT DOESN'T,
THAT'S A QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE, THE ADMINISTRATION,
TO DETERMINE A PATH FORWARD IF
IT DESIRES CHANGES TO BENEFIT
LEVELS. ADJUSTING BENEFIT LEVELS
IN THE UI PROGRAM HAS BEEN A
LONG STANDING INTEREST OF THE
LEGISLATURES SINCE I STARTED ON
THE ASSIGNMENT SEVEN YEARS AGO,
CHANGES HAVE NOT BEEN MADE IN
PART CERTAINLY DUE TO THE FISCAL
CONDITION OF THE UI TRUST FUND,
THE FUND HAS DIFFICULTY
GENERATING THE CONTRIBUTIONS
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM TO PAY
FOR BENEFITS. SO WHAT DO YOU SEE
AS A SOLUTION IN OUR OFFICE HAS
NO FORMAL SOLUTION AT HAND, BUT
WE WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU, THE COMMITTEE
STAFF, YOUR PERSONAL STAFF,
OTHER SENATORS ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
SOLUTIONS. SO THE REASON WHY I
BRING THIS UP, AND I KNOW I
BROUGHT IT UP TO THE DIRECTOR
WHEN WE HAD OUR ONE ON ONE. AND
GRANTED, THIS IS A LITTLE BIT,
YOU KNOW, I KNOW A LITTLE
DIFFICULT FOR YOU GUYS RIGHT NOW
TO BE HERE AND ASKING BEING
ASKED THE QUESTION I REALLY WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT TO THE LARGER
PUBLIC MY FRUSTRATION WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE ACROSS
THE BOARD. I UNDERSTAND WHERE
THE BUSINESSES LIE, AND HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS FOR SMALLER
BUSINESSES TO BE ABLE TO KEEP UP
WITH INCREASED COSTS AND SO
FORTH. UTILITIES ARE THROUGH THE
ROOF, RENT IS THROUGH THE ROOF,
GROCERIES ARE THROUGH THE ROOF,
YOU NAME IT, BUT THE FACT THAT
IT HASN'T CHANGED EVEN TO A COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT YEAR OVER
YEAR, IT IS PROBLEMATIC. NUMBER
ONE, NUMBER TWO IS THE MERE FACT
THAT. AND I'M GONNA BE QUITE
FRANK, I CONSTANTLY HEAR ALMOST
EVERY ELECTED INDIVIDUAL WILL
SPEAK ABOUT HOW WE'RE THE FOURTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. AS
A PROUD POINT, RIGHT. AND WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
ARE HARD WORKING. THESE ARE NOT
HANDOUTS. THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WORKED A JOB THAT, FOR
WHATEVER REASON, GOT LAID OFF OR
SO FORTH, THAT ALSO PAY INTO
THIS SYSTEM TO SOME DEGREE,
RIGHT, THAT WITH THE WORK, WITH
TRYING TO FIND ANOTHER JOB, THEY
CANNOT MAINTAIN THEIR BASIC COST
OF LIVING. SO I'M VERY
DISAPPOINTED IN THIS, AND I KNOW
THAT THIS IS NOT, YOU KNOW,
NECESSARILY FOR YOU GUYS RIGHT
NOW, BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE BE WORKED ON
MOVING FORWARD, MYSELF INCLUDED.
I WOULD LOVE TO PARTNER IN SOME
WAY ABOUT THIS, RIGHT. AND FIND
SOME SOLUTION THAT IS REASONABLE
AND AN ADJUSTMENT AT THIS POINT,
ANYTHING IS BETTER THAN WHAT WE
HAVE RIGHT, SO I WOULD LIKE A
COMMITMENT FROM YOU ALL TO
PRIORITIZE THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE IN THE YEAR TO COME,
TWO YEARS TO COME, SO FORTH. AND
THE FACT THAT, YOU KNOW, WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS FUND IN
PARTICULAR, WE HAD ONE OF THE
LARGEST. WINDFALLS OF MONEY
RIGHT, IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
AND NOW AS A FRESHMAN SENATOR,
I'M COMING IN TO A DOWNTURN.
RIGHT. A POTENTIAL SILENT
RECESSION. DEBATABLE FOR SOME.
RIGHT. BUT IT IS VERY MUCH TRUE
FOR A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE
WORKING PEOPLE, SO I WANT TO SEE
WHERE WE CAN BALANCE IT OFF. BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY, IN MY DISTRICT
, WE ARE SEEING IN MY DISTRICT
OF THE EAST BAY AND SOUTH BAY IN
THE BAY AREA, WE ARE SEEING
LAYOFFS ACROSS THE BOARD. RIGHT.
AND THE COST OF HOUSING, SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES OR APARTMENTS AND
SO FORTH IS WELL OVER $2,000,
WELL OVER RIGHT. FOR AN
APARTMENT 2500, SO FORTH. RIGHT.
SO HOW DO YOU PAY FOR YOUR RENT?
PAY FOR GROCERIES, PAY FOR YOUR
CAR, PAY FOR INSURANCE, PAY FOR
WHATEVER. IF YOUR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CAN EVEN FLOAT YOU
UNTIL YOU FIND THE NEXT JOB. SO
TO ME, IT'S A PROBLEM TO MY
DISTRICT IS A PROBLEM. AND I
HOPE THAT, YOU KNOW, WE ALL SEE
SOME ACTION ON THIS. SO THANK
YOU, SENATOR SARDO WILL FOLLOW
UP ON ON THAT CONVERSATION. I
DON'T ED IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
COLLECTING THE MONEY THAT WE
TELL THEM COLLECT AND DISPERSING
THAT AS MUCH AS THEY CAN, IF
THEY WERE GIVING OUT MONEY IN
THE AMOUNTS THAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT, WE'D HAVE A LOT
LESS BUSINESSES THAT WOULD BE
EVEN SUPPLYING THE JOB FOR
SOMEBODY TO HAVE A JOB TO LOSE
IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND, AND I
THINK THE BIGGER ECONOMY IS WHAT
THE ISSUE IS FOR US TO GRAPPLE
WITH IN THE STATE. AND I DON'T
FEEL LIKE, YOU KNOW, THE FOLKS
AT EDD ARE THE KEY TO
AFFORDABILITY IN CALIFORNIA. THE
KEY TO AFFORDABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA IS ENSURING THAT FROM
THE HOUSING STANDPOINT, THAT WE
DO POLICIES THAT ENCOURAGE
HOUSING WITHOUT INCREASING THE
PRICE OF EVERY HOUSE. AND WE'RE
NOT DOING THAT. AND SO I DON'T
WANT TO SEE US LAYING THIS OFF
AND HAVING ED WALK OUT OF HERE
FEELING LIKE THEY'RE THE
CULPRITS AND WHY PEOPLE AREN'T
GETTING THE MONEY THAT THEY NEED
IN THEIR INSURANCE, THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO SUPPLY
A WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT,
WHICH IS A HUGE, COST OF LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAS BEEN
CREATED BY POLICIES IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE LAST 30
YEARS. I APPRECIATE THAT. I
UNDERSTAND, AND HOWEVER, ALSO ED
TAKES A HOLISTIC APPROACH AS TO
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE SYSTEM
AT HAND. WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AS WELL,
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD TALK
AND IT SHOULD BE FLAGGED TO US
WHEN WE'RE TALKING TO ED, THAT
THIS IS NOT ENOUGH MONEY,
PERIOD. SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
AGAIN, I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME,
AND I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN GET
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO WHAT
YOU GUYS SEE MOVING FORWARD, WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE, GENERAL C, CDB
UPDATES AND GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
.
HELLO THERE. UP HERE. FEEL FREE
TO JUMP BACK HERE. YES EVERYBODY
GET A CHANCE TO COMMENT OKAY.
WE'LL DO SOME
.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ANDREW MARCH. CHAZ ALAMO, AND I
APOLOGIZE. KIANA PEREIRA. VERY
CLOSE. CHYNA. CHYNA. SORRY.
WHO'S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CW. CDB, WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
THIS IS OUR LAST DISCUSSION
ITEM, ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. AND
WE'RE FIRST GOING TO HEAR FROM
ANDREW MARCH. THANK YOU. ANDREW
MÁS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
REDUCTIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD. AS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA, THE LOW
CARBON ECONOMY GRANT PROGRAM AND
THE HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS, SPECIFICALLY THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PORTION OF THAT, HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS QUICK, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO AHEAD, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. MY NAME IS
CONNOR PEREIRA'S. I'M NOW THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD, VERY RECENTLY
ADDED. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
THE AMAZING WORK THAT IS BEING
DONE AT THE BOARD LEVEL AND WITH
OUR PARTNERS ON THE FIELD. SO
I'M GOING TO GIVE VERY GENERAL
HIGH LEVEL, BREAKDOWNS OF WHAT
THE CURRENT PROGRAMS ARE DOING,
HOW THOSE PARTNERSHIPS ARE
ENABLED, AND THEN ALSO THOSE WHO
ARE HAVE BEEN PARTICIPATING IN
THESE PROGRAMS TO DATE. SO IN
RELATION TO THE HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP, WE HAVE 95
TOTAL PARTNERSHIPS, 88 OF WHICH
ARE ACTIVE AND THE REMAINING
ACTIVE CONTRACTS ARE IN PLACE
AND SHOULD BE EXECUTED BY THE
JULY 1ST DATE. UNDER THE HIGH
ROAD CONSTRUCTION CAREERS
PROGRAM, THERE ARE 13 CURRENTLY
UNDER CONTRACT, AND IN BOTH OF
THESE PROGRAMS COMBINED,
PARTICIPANTS SERVE TO DATE TOTAL
2333. THERE ARE FIVE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ACTIVE UNDER OTHER FUNDS RELATED
TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMING UNDER BOTH HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP
COLLABORATIVES FOR THE LOW
CARBON ECONOMY GRANT, WHICH WAS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY, AND IN
THAT CASE THERE ARE TEN
CURRENTLY FUNDED AND 27 DIRECTLY
SERVED TO DATE. HOWEVER, THE
FUNDING IS ONLY STARTED IN THE
LAST MONTH, AS FAR AS GETTING
OUT INTO THE FIELD FOR HCP
HEALTH CARE OR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PORTION, THERE ARE 23
THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
CONTRACT, 12 FROM THE 2223
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION AND 11
FROM THE 2324 ALLOCATION, THOSE
PARTICIPANTS SERVED TO DATE
THROUGH THE 12 PROJECTS IN THE
2022 2023 PERIOD ARE 631. WE
HAVE NO DATA YET ON THOSE
CONTRACTED IN 2324 AS IT RELATES
TO REGIONAL EQUITY AND RECOVERY
OF THE PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM, HTTP AND HRC BREAKING
BARRIERS PROGRAMS. THERE ARE
EIGHT CURRENTLY ACTIVE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN SERVING
PARTICIPANTS SINCE APRIL 1ST OF
2024, AND CURRENTLY HAVE 8092
UNDER SERVICE, THAT CLOSES THE
DETAILS OF THOSE PROGRAMS. HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
, SENATOR DURAZZO. YES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND
CONGRATULATIONS, I THINK THANK
YOU. YOUR NEW POSITION, I THINK
SO I HOPE IT'S CONGRATULATIONS,
HOW LONG HAVE YOU. I WAS SWORN
IN ON THE 27TH OF MARCH, BUT
THEN TOOK A LITTLE BIT OF
VACATION, AND I ACTUALLY STARTED
ON THE FOURTH VACATION. AND YOU
JUST GOT SWORN IN? YES. IT WAS
MORE OF AN ACCOUNTING THING TO
KEEP MY HEALTH INSURANCE
ACTUALLY. ANYWAY, WELL,
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE ENOUGH
BACKGROUND TO ANSWER SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS, AS PART OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS, A FEW YEARS AGO,
THE ADMINISTRATION AGREED TO
LANGUAGE, THAT REQUIRES THE
BOARD TO SET POLICY TO FURTHER
DEFINE HIGH ROAD, STANDARDS, SO
IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT, WHAT
DO YOU WHAT DO YOU SEE THE PLAN
AND THE TIMELINE, TO IMPLEMENT
THIS STATUTE THROUGH YOUR BOARD,
YOU SEE IT COMING UP IN YOUR
BOARD AGENDAS. HOW DO YOU SEE IT
MOVING FORWARD AT THIS TIME? I
KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING TO THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE FOR THE NEXT BOARD
HEARING, WHICH IS SCHEDULED IN
MAY, THIS IS ONE OF THE TOPICS
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS
TO SEE IF IT'S GOING TO BE
INCLUDED ON THE DOCKET. THERE'S
ALSO, IN RELATION TO ANOTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE PRIORITY, WHICH
IS THE CALIFORNIA JOBS FIRST
INITIATIVE. AND HOW ARE WE GOING
TO FOLD IN, THE HIGH ROAD
LANGUAGE AND INFORMATION
UNDERNEATH THAT NEW UMBRELLA
PROGRAM? SO THERE'S STILL MORE
TO COME. I'M EAGER TO WORK WITH
BOTH THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE AND
THE FULL BOARD TO UNDERSTAND HOW
TO ESTABLISH THOSE POLICIES AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY FOLD
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PRIORITY BRAND AS WELL. OKAY.
SPEAKING OF YOUR BOARD, SO AT
YOUR MARCH 27TH MEETING, A BOARD
MEMBER MADE A MOTION THAT THE
BOARD CONSIDER AND ADOPT POLICY
ON REQUIRING LABOR EQUITY AND
CLIMATE STANDARDS AND,
ENFORCEMENT GOVERNING, THE
DEPLOYMENT OF FEDERAL AND STATE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND RELATED PROJECTS. I'M NOT
SURE WHY A MEMBER OF THE BOARD
WAS BLOCKED FROM MAKING A
MOTION, BUT, HOW DO YOU SEE
ADDRESSING THAT? BECAUSE IT
DIRECTLY HAS TO DO WITH WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. HIGH ROAD
STANDARDS. YEAH. UNFORTUNATELY,
I, I WAS NOT PRESENT FOR THE
MEETING. I HAVE REVIEWED SOME OF
THE NOTES FROM THE STAFF, AS
WELL AS WATCH THE, THE YOUTUBE,
WHATEVER OF IT, BUT AT THIS TIME
, I DON'T REALLY KNOW WHY THOSE
WHY THOSE ISSUES CAME UP OR WHY
THE MOTION WAS NOT ALLOWED.
HOWEVER, I INSTRUCTED STAFF,
ALONG WITH MYSELF TO REVIEW BOTH
THE GUIDELINES AND WHAT BOARD
SHOULD BE DOING AND WHAT THEY
CAN BE DOING TO ENSURE THAT IN
FUTURE PRACTICE, WE ARE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE REQUESTS AS
NECESSARY. YEAH, AND I SAY THIS
BECAUSE IT WAS OBVIOUSLY
SOMETHING WE WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO, IT'S YOU KNOW, THIS
IS FROM SB 150 AND ALL THE STEPS
THAT WERE TAKEN AND THE REPORT
WAS GOING TO BE SUBMITTED AND
THEN ACTION TAKEN. SO I'M, I'M
JUST REALLY DISAPPOINTED THAT
THAT PROCESS HAS BEEN DISRUPTED
AND THERE'S NO EXPLANATION FOR
IT. TO MY KNOWLEDGE, THE REPORT
WAS DUE TWO DAYS AFTER THE BOARD
MEETING ON 327, AND THERE WAS
INCORPORATED LANGUAGE INTO THE
FINAL REPORT ILLUSTRATING THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT WAS RECEIVED BY
CALDB. HOWEVER, I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT IT WAS EXPLICITLY INDICATED
WITHIN THE REPORT AT THAT TIME.
OKAY, AND, HOW HOW DO YOU SEE
YOURSELF SUPPORTING, LABOR
MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIPS,
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TO
EQUITY AND, AND JOB QUALITY, AND
STRENGTHENING THE HIGH ROAD
DEFINITION. SO, YOU KNOW, I COME
FROM A BACKGROUND, I WAS
FORMERLY WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND, YOU KNOW, WAS
IN CHARGE OF BOTH BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES AS WELL AS
EXPANDING OUR INDUSTRIAL
FOOTPRINT. SO IN A LOT OF SENSE,
IT'S UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE
SUPPLY AND DEMAND LOOKS LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO BRING IN THE PROGRAMS
OF SKILLED AND TRAINED NECESSITY
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE WE'RE
PUTTING PROGRAMS TOGETHER THAT
ACTUALLY LEAD TO GOOD PAYING
JOBS, THAT ARE ACTUALLY JOBS OF
THE FUTURE. AND SO FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, IT'S GOING TO BE
BOTH INCORPORATING WHAT IT WOULD
BE, AN INDUSTRIAL POLICY
DIRECTIVE IN TERMS OF HOW ARE WE
GOING TO SEE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT THE DEMANDS
LOOK LIKE. THEREFORE, UNDER
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE SKILLS NEEDS
AND THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
DIRECT ENGAGEMENT WITH BOTH THE
BUSINESSES, THE COMMUNITIES AND
THE ACTUAL PRACTITIONERS, ALONG
WITH THOSE WHO ARE INTENDING TO
SERVE. SO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A
HOLISTIC APPROACH IN TERMS OF
INDUSTRIAL ENGAGEMENT AND TRYING
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THOSE NEW
CRITICAL AREAS ARE OF INVESTMENT
ARE GOING TO BE FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. SO THAT WAY WE CAN
SEED THAT INVESTMENT AND WITHIN
OUR REGIONAL BOARDS AND OUR
LOCAL BOARDS MORE EFFECTIVELY.
BUT WITH REGARDS TO EQUITY AND
JOB QUALITY. YEAH. SO EQUITY AND
JOB QUALITY ARE PARAMOUNT OF
BOTH THE HR PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
EVERYTHING THAT THIS BOARD
STANDS FOR. AND SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE, THAT IS AN EMBEDDED
MEASURE THAT WILL BE REALLY
COUNTED ON IN EVERY STEP AND
ENSURED THROUGH WHAT THE
GUIDELINES THAT ARE DEVELOPED AS
WELL AS THE MEASURABLE OUTCOMES
THAT WE REQUIRE FROM THE
SUBCONTRACTORS AND THE AWARDEES
OF THESE GRANTS. OKAY, BECAUSE
THE REASON SB 150 WAS NEEDED WAS
TO BE MORE EXPLICIT AND HAVE A
CLEARER WAY OF DOING THAT,
RATHER THAN ENDING UP WITH
MINIMUM WAGE JOBS WHERE, YOU
KNOW, THE BUSINESS COULD SAY,
WELL, WE'RE WE'RE LIVING UP TO
ALL THE, THE LEGAL LABOR
STANDARDS, LEGAL LABOR STANDARDS
AT $15 AN HOUR. JUST DON'T CUT
IT. YEAH. I THINK IT'S THE
BOARD'S DESIRE TO NEVER LOOK AT
THE LEGAL STANDARD AS THE
REQUIREMENT. BUT WHAT IS THE
OPTIMAL STANDARD OR WHAT IS A
FAMILY SUPPORTING WAGE IN THAT
RESPECT? OKAY, GREAT. AND THEN,
AN ON THE AB 398 REPORT, WHAT IF
YOU CAN PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON
THAT AND, YOUR PLANS TO
IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS SUCH
AS LABOR STANDARDS, ESPECIALLY
WITH REGARDS, I'VE BEEN REALLY
INTERESTED IN THE NON
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE WE HAVE SO
MUCH EXPERIENCE WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND INDUSTRIES
AND CAREERS, BUT WE HAVE VERY
LITTLE, AND WE ALWAYS SEEM TO
SHOVE IT ASIDE, WHICH IS
MANUFACTURING AND CLIMATE
PROJECTS. SO HOW DO YOU SEE THE
PLANS TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS? TO BE HONEST,
I'M NOT FULLY READ IN ON THE
DYNAMICS OF AB 328. AND WE'LL
GET BACK TO YOU WITH SOME
SPECIFICS AFTER I AM ABLE TO
MEET WITH STAFF. OKAY. AB THREE
Þ 398 I DON'T EVEN KNOW THE
NUMBER OKAY, I APOLOGIZE. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
YOU'RE GOOD. THANK YOU GUYS FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE HAS A
CHANCE TO BE HEARD. PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO 30S AND IF
SOMEONE ELSE HAS ALREADY MADE A
SIMILAR COMMENT, PLEASE JUST ADD
A ME TOO. THANK YOU AND LET'S
BEGIN. PUBLIC COMMENT. ALL
RIGHT. HI MY NAME IS NOEMI WOODS
AND I AM HERE TODAY REPRESENTING
THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL COALITION
WITH OVER 125 MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS. THE SAFETY NET
FOR ALL COALITION IS REQUESTING
$250,000 TO ADVANCE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
RESIDENTS BY INCORPORATING
ELEMENTS OF AN EXCLUDED WORKER
PROGRAM INTO THE NEXT
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS TO THE
STATE BY AVOIDING FUTURE
DUPLICATIVE COSTS, AND THE
PROPOSAL IS TIMELY. ED NEXT IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ON UPGRADES
THAT WOULD ADVANCE THIS PROGRAM.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR SUPPORT
AND ADVANCING A SAFETY NET FOR
ALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY. SALATA. FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SOME QUICK
COMMENTS ON ALL THE AREAS.
FIRST, THE ERICA GRANTS, SO MUCH
OF THE FUNDING GOT AWARDED, AND
GOT HANDED TO THE PARTNERS IN
EARLY JANUARY. SO IT'S SO HARD
TO GET THE RESULTS IN SO EARLY
ON, THE, ERICA GRANT, PART OF IT
AND ALSO ON ED, WE NEED TO RAISE
THE RATE. CALIFORNIA IS THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
CALIFORNIA, AND PEOPLE CANNOT
LIVE OFF OF THAT, AND FINALLY,
AROUND, THE WORKFORCE HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP. WE ARE
REQUEST ING $25 MILLION FROM,
FROM, THE CALIFORNIA JOBS FIRST
TO SUPPORT HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS. THE CURRENT BUDGET
HAS ZERO, FUNDING GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. HELLO, I'M BECCA
ROSENBAUM. I'M THE CHIEF
STRATEGY OFFICER OF JVS, A
LEADING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY BASED IN THE BAY AREA AND
OPERATING THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
JVS HAS RECEIVED OVER $5 MILLION
FROM THE HTTP PROGRAM AND HAS
SUCCESSFULLY TRAINED AND PLACED
PEOPLE IN HIGH DEMAND,
WELL-PAYING CAREERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THE HTTP FUNDING IS
NOW ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK,
LEAVING THE FUTURE OF COUNTLESS
JOB SEEKERS HANGING IN THE
BALANCE. JOB SEEKERS SUCH AS
JORDAN HERNANDEZ AND HTTP ALUM,
WHO STRUGGLED FOR YEARS TO FIND
A CAREER THAT NOT ONLY PAID THE
BILLS, BUT ALSO PROVIDED
STABILITY, BENEFITS AND ROOM TO
GROW THROUGH A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN JVS AND LOCAL WATER AND
WASTEWATER AGENCIES, JORDAN
RECEIVED FREE TRAINING FOR A NEW
CAREER. THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME
IS TAMINA. I WORK FOR BLUEGREEN
ALLIANCE. BLUEGREEN IS A
NATIONAL COALITION OF LABOR
UNION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATION WORKING TOGETHER TO
FACILITATE TRANSITION TO A CLEAN
ECONOMY THAT PROTECTS THE PLANET
AND ALSO WORKERS. IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY TRAINING
FOR WORKERS. HTTPS R
COLLABORATIVE ARRANGEMENTS
BETWEEN EMPLOYERS, LABOR UNIONS
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS. THE CONTRA COSTA
REFINERY TRANSITION PLAN, WHICH
BGA IS LEADING, IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THIS. THIS HTTP
PROGRAM IS A COALITION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS, LABOR UNIONS AND
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS. WORK
TOGETHER. HELLO. SYLVIA ROMO, A
DIRECTOR OF SYSTEMS CHANGE WITH
THE BUILDING SKILLS PARTNERSHIP.
WE REPRESENT UNIONIZED PROPERTY
SERVICE WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE, AND WE ARE A HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP. URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PRESERVE HRP
FUNDING. IT HAS BEEN ESSENTIAL
IN HELPING US TO SERVE THE
IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE. THAT HELPS
KEEP CLEAN AND SUSTAINABLE AND
SAFE BUILDING FACILITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. NOW IS NOT THE TIME
FOR THE STATE TO SUDDENLY, MOVE
THIS WORKFORCE FROM BEING
CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL DURING A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS TO BEING
EXPENDABLE. THEY ARE WORTHY AND
DESERVING OF CONTINUED
INVESTMENT FOR IMPROVED JOB
QUALITY AND CAREER AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY. SO WE PROVIDE A ME Tê
TO PROVIDING THE $25 MILLION OF
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND ANYBODY THAT
HAS ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. AGAIN,
WE'RE TAKING 30S OF COMMENTS. IF
YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS,
YOU CAN ALWAYS EMAIL US OR CALL
STAFF AND LET THEM KNOW HOW YOU
GUYS FEEL. 30S. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. I'M LORENZO SILVA WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
HERE AS A PART OF THE SAFETY NET
COALITION. I'M HERE TO ASK YOU
TO THE SUPPORT THE REQUEST FOR
THE 250,000 TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM WITH ADT NEXT. AND I
WILL ASK EVERYBODY THAT IT IS
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE SAFETY
NET FOR ALL PROGRAM TO STAND UP
AND SAY IN SUPPORT TODOS ESTAN
AQUI EL DIA DE HOY PARA APOYAR
EL PROGRAMA DE SAFETY NET FOR
ALL SI SE PUEDEN PONER DE PIE,
POR FAVOR PARA C¯ S¼ MUESTRA EL
APOYO DE LA COMUNIDAD. I KNOW WE
JUST HAVE 30S, BUT YOU MENTIONED
IT THAT $350 IS NOT ENOUGH TO
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. THE PROGRAM,
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A
PENNY. IT IS DOCUMENTED THAT
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS, THEY
PROVIDE LIKE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO CALIFORNIA ON TAXES, AND THEY
ARE NOT RECEIVING EVEN A PENNY
BACK. SO ON YOUR WORDS, WE NEED
TO DO MORE WORK ON. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. PRISCILLA CROSS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES, NÓ. AS
A CEO, WHERE EMPLOYMENT, SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE, OPERATING THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA, PROVIDING EMPLOYMENT
TO INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
RETURNING FROM INCARCERATION, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE STATE IS
FACING A LARGE BUDGET DEFICIT,
BUT WE STRONGLY URGE LEGISLATORS
TO NOT MAKE ANY ADDITIONAL
REDUCTIONS. THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD, BUT
INSTEAD ENCOURAGE INVESTMENTS
TOWARDS THE REENTRY POPULATION
PROGRAM, SUCH AS HIRING JUSTICE
INVOLVED REENTRY INITIATIVE THAT
PROVIDES A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
THE REENTRY FOCUS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO, EVERYONE. MY
NAME IS YESENIA BARRERA, AN
ORGANIZER WITH THE WAREHOUSE
WORKERS RESOURCE CENTER, BUT
ALSO PART OF THE SAFETY NET FOR
ALL COALITION. I AM ASKING YOU
TO INTEGRATE AN INSURANCE
PROGRAM FOR EXCLUDED WORKERS
THROUGH THE EDD NEXT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS RACHEL
CHURCH. I AM PART OF PARENT
VOICES SAN FRANCISCO HERE TODAY
TO SUPPORT SAFETY NET FOR ALL. I
AM ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
INTEGRATE AN INSURANCE PROGRAM
FOR EXCLUDED WORKERS THROUGH EDD
NEXT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS JORGE LUNA
WITH VALLEY VOICES SERVING IN
THE COMMUNITY OF KINGS COUNTY,
LIKE, MY COLLEAGUES HAVE VOICE.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SAFETY NET
FOR ALL AND IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKER OUTREACH
PROJECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BUENOS DIAS A TODOS. MY NAME IS
ELIAS. SEGUIR EL PUEBLO DE LOS
TRABAJADORES AND SOY DE CONCORD,
CALIFORNIA. GRACIAS THANK YOU.
YES, MY NAME IS MARIA. BINGO. I
AM THE SAN FRANCISCO INTEGRATED
PROGRAMA DE TRABAJADORES.
GRACIAS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MY NAME IS DANIELA
ESPARZA WITH ICAC FROM SAN
BERNARDINO. I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SWAP. THANK YOU, HI. MY NAME
IS ALMA FELIZ. I COME FROM SAN
FRANCISCO, AND I SUPPORT THE. I
WORK AS A CAREGIVER AND I
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM SAFE. SAFE
TO SAY SORRY. Ó SAFETY NET FOR
ALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BUENAS. BUENOS DIAS. A VIVO AQUI
IN SACRAMENTO. ME NOMBRE ES
ELENA RODRIGUEZ E VENGO
REPRESENTANDO A LA SEGURIDAD. A
SEGURIDAD DE. UNIDOS PARA TODOS
TANTO DE LA ASOCIACION DE
LIDERES ÓRDENES. MUCHAS GRACIAS.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS BEN
TAKAMOTO. I REPRESENT VALLEY
FORWARD IN FRESNO COUNTY. I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKER OUTREACH
PROGRAM AND SAFETY NET FOR ALL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS
BURTON BRISBANE WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO SAU AND MOYAMOYA
ACTIVIST. EVEN THOUGH LA CIUDAD
PARA TODOS, I AM COMING FROM MUA
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. I AM ASKING
THAT PLEASE THINK ABOUT SAFETY
FOR ALL. THANKS THANK YOU. HELLO
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS ARTURO.
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH ICAC
AND THE PICO NETWORK AND HERE IN
SUPPORT WITH THE SWAP. AND I DO
ASK THAT YOU GUYS GIVE THE REST
OF US YOUR FULL ATTENTION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BUENOS DIAS PARA
TODOS. YO SOY ARMANDO ORDONEZ.
QUISIERA QUÊ PROGRAMING EL
SEGUNDO PARA TODOS A TRAVÉS DEL
PROGRAMA DE PORQUE NO SOLO LA
PANDEMIA. NECESITAMOS ESA AYUDA,
SINO TAMBIÉN POR ENFERMEDAD Y
MUCHAS OTRAS COSAS MAS LA
SEGURIDAD. NO ES SOLO PARA ME ES
MAS PARA NUESTROS HIJOS. MUCHAS
GRACIAS. HI. I'M ASKING FOR
SAFETY FOR ALL. AND BECAUSE IT'S
NOT JUST FOR US, THAT IS ALSO
FOR ALL OUR FAMILY. PLEASE.
THANKS. THANK YOU. WANNA START?
MY NAME IS JORGE ORTIZ VIVO IN
OXNARD, CALIFORNIA. CONDADO DE
VENTURA, LIPIDO INTEGRANTE UN
PROGRAMA DE SEGUROS PARA
ESCOLHIDOS A TRAVÉS DE NEXT
WEEK, THEN UN ANO MAS PARA
FONDOS PARA COR. GRACIAS. THANK
YOU. HELLO, MY NAME IS JORGE
TOLEDO AND I COME FROM OXNARD,
CALIFORNIA, AND I'M ASKING YOU
TO INTEGRATE THE PROGRAM OF
SAFETY NET FOR ALL, WHERE IT.
YEP AND, FOR IT TO COME WITH
ANOTHER WITH ANOTHER YEAR OF
FUNDING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI. MY NAME IS MEGAN WHALEN. I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKERS COALITION. I WANT TO
START WITH THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
SHRINKING THE SHORTFALL IN THE
EXISTING PROPOSAL. THE DOMESTIC
WORKER EDUCATION OUTREACH
PROGRAM IS STILL EXISTING, AND
WE JUST WANT TO APPRECIATE AND
HOPE THAT IT'S PRESERVED IN THIS
COMING YEAR AND ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF SWAP AND SAFETY NET FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI, MY
NAME IS OLIVIA. I LIVE IN
OAKLAND AND ALSO FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION AND ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK AND
PRESERVING THE FUNDS FOR THE
DOMESTIC WORKER AND EMPLOYER
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH PROGRAM,
AND HOPE THAT THAT CONTINUES TO
BE A PRIORITY IN THE BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. HOLA OTRA VEZ.
SALUDOS SENADORA DURAZO ESTE
BINGO APOYAR DE THE EDUCACION Y
ALCANCE PARA LOS TRABAJADORES
DEL LUGAR DE LA COLECTIVA DE
MUJERES Y EL DE LABOR. TAMBIÉN
ES DE LA PROPUESTA DEL ED ES MUY
IMPORTANTE PARA TODOS LOS
TRABAJADORES. LE PIDO ESTE
INTEGRAL. EL PROGRAMA DE SEGURO
PARA TODOS LOS TRABAJADORES
EXCLUIDOS C¯ LES ES TAMBIÉN LA
PROPUESTA DE COR GRACIAS. THANK
YOU, HI. I'M I'M COMING HERE
FROM THE ORIGINAL COLLECTIVE OF
WOMEN AND DAILY LABORS. AND
PLEASE, IF YOU CAN SUPPORT THE
SB 227, SWAP AND ALSO THE
EDUCATIONAL OUTREACH FOR ALL
WORKERS. THANK YOU. HOLA. ERIKA
CHÁVEZ, SOY DE SAN FRANCISCO,
CALIFORNIA. LA COLECTIVA DE
MUJERES DE LABOR PROGRAM. SALAS
ESTOY AQUI PARA PEDIRLE QUEDO
EXCLUSIVO A TRAVÉS DE EDDIE. THE
NEXT IS WHAT SB DOES DOCE SIETE
EL PROGRAMA DE EDUCACION ALCANCE
DE TRABAJADORES DEL HOGAR. HE SI
SE PUEDE. GRACIAS. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS ERIKA CHÁVEZ
FROM SAN FRANCISCO, CALIFORNIA,
OF THE WOMEN'S COLLECTIVE AND
DAY LABOR PROGRAM. THE ORIGINAL,
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT TO FOR
YOU IN SUPPORT OF THE ED PROGRAM
AND SEE WHAT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY HOLA. MUY BUENOS DIAS.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH MONTIEL.
YO, VIVO IN SAN FRANCISCO. SOY
DE LA COALITION DE TRABAJADOR DE
LUGAR Â ESTOY EN LA
ORGANIZACION DE MUJERES UNIDAS
DE ACTIVAS. YO QUIERO SER
USTEDES C¯ NOS AYUDAN A QUÉ ESTÁ
COMO SE DICE ESTE ESTE PROGRAMA
PARA NOSOTROS LOS TRABAJADORES
COLONIAS SOMOS PARA EDUCAR LOS
TRABAJADORES PORQUE MUCHAS VECES
DE VERDAD DE VERDAD QUÊ LOS
TRABAJADORES. LOS LOS
EMPLEADORES. ELLOS TODAVIA NO
ESTAN EDUCADO ES 11 AND TODO LO
C¯ LES EXIGEN A LAS TRABAJADORAS
Y QUÊ VIVA LAS MUJERES. THANK
YOU. YEAH, I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION AND MUJERES UNIDAS
ACTIVAS. I LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR DOMESTIC WORKERS, WE
FOR EDUCATION AND FOR EMPLOYERS,
BECAUSE WE CONTINUE TO SUFFER
FROM LABOR ABUSES AND LONG LIVE
WOMEN. THANK YOU. HELLO, I AM
LORENA, I LIVE IN HAYWARD. I AM
A LEADER MEMBER OF MÐI AND
DOMESTIC WORKERS COALITION, AND
I AM HERE TO SUPPORT THE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH BUDGET
FOR LABOR PROTECTIONS FOR
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES IN THE
DOMESTIC WORK INDUSTRY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO THERE. MY
NAME IS ARCENEAUX ORIHUELA. I AM
FROM CONCORD AND WORK AS A
EMERGING BUSINESS COORDINATOR AT
MONUMENT IMPACT. I AM ASKING YOU
TO INTEGRATE AN INSURANCE
PROGRAM FOR EXCLUDED WORKERS
THROUGH ED. EDD NEXT. AND JUST
AS A REMINDER, I WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT ACCORDING TO RESEARCH,
IMMIGRANTS WORKERS WILL ADD AN
EXTRA 7 TRILLION TO THE U.S.
ECONOMY WITHIN THE NEXT DECADE
AND AN EXTRA 1 TRILLION IN
FEDERAL TAX REVENUE. AGAIN, 1
TRILLION IN FEDERAL TAX REVENUE.
WELL, LU█N DÍAS MY NAME IS MARIA
AGUILAR WITH THE ORANGE TRABAJO
COMO JANITOR LAUP HÌ COMO PIDO
KINDERGARTEN. UN PROGRAMA DE
SEGURIDAD PARA TRABAJADORES
EXCLUIDOS A TRAVÉS DE LA VIDA.
GRACIAS. THANK YOU. FOR
STARTERS, ME NAME IS ROGER.
ESTOY AQUI PARA SEGURIDAD PARA
TODOS GUILLUM PARA EL AUDIENCIA
DE RÁPIDAMENTE HUESO DISENADO ME
NOMBRE ROGER IN SAN FRANCISCO DE
TRABAJO DE ASSISTANT DE MACEDO
LES PIDO Kò INTEGRATION PROGRAMA
DE SEGURO PARA TRABAJADORES A
TRAVÉS DE EDDIE. NEXT. GRACIAS
THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME IS ROGER.
I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO. I WORK
AS AN ASSISTANT WAITER, AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
INTEGRATE AND ENSURE PROGRAM FOR
THE EXCLUDED WORKERS THROUGH
EDDIE. MY NAME IS HUMBERTO
CANTU. BINGO. REPRESENTANDO. THE
RED DE SEGURIDAD. YO TRABAJO EN
RESTAURANTES E VENIMOS PROGRAMA
DE TRABAJADORES DE ALEJO'S Â ES
LO QUÊ NOSOTROS QUEREMOS PARA
LOS EMPLEADOS C¯ CANNOT PRESTEN
ATENCION DE TODOS LOS TRABAJOS
CONTAMOS HACIENDO EN LAS EN LOS
RESTAURANTES. GRACIAS THANK YOU.
HELLO, MY NAME IS HUMBERTO CANTU
AND I CAME HERE IN SUPPORT FOR
THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL. I'M A
RESTAURANT WORKER AND I'M HERE
ALSO TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE PAY
ATTENTION TO THE WORK THAT WE DO
IN THE RESTAURANTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS AIDA AMADO AND I AM
INVESTIGATOR FOR MCTF AND THIS
IS MY SECOND TIME HERE AND I
WILL BE BACK IF IT IS NECESSARY.
AND I SUPPORT OUR, SAFETY FOR
ALL. AND I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
INVITE TO UNION TO ALL OF US,
BECAUSE WE ARE THE COMMUNITY AND
WE NEED THE RIVAS PARA TODOS Â
PARA NUESTROS HIJOS. GRACIAS
MARIKO YOSHIHARA, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WORKER POWER, JUST WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR PRESERVING
SWAP AND DWOP FUNDING. IT WAS
GREAT TO HEAR THE COMMENTS FROM
THE AGENCY TODAY. REALLY SHOWING
THE IMPORTANCE OF SWAP FOR
WORKER OUTREACH AND EDUCATION.
THIS IS NOT PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL, BUT WE ARE
ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL 30
MILLION OF SWAP FUNDING JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE ALSO
SUPPORT SAFETY NET FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND BEFORE
YOU GUYS BEGIN, I JUST WANT TO
MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT. WE'VE
ALREADY GONE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME REGARDING PUBLIC
COMMENTS, I ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY
TO STATE ME TOO, IF THEY BELONG
TO THE SAME ORGANIZATION, WHICH
MANY OF YOU GUYS DO, AND WE WILL
BE CUTTING OFF PUBLIC COMMENTS
AT 12:00. SO THERE'S ROUGHLY
ANOTHER TEN MINUTES. SO JUST
GIVE YOU GUYS ALL A HEADS UP.
WHEN TO START. MY NAME IS GABINO
VENGO DEL BARRIO CENTRAL. SOY UN
TRABAJADOR DEL CAMPO DE VENGO
PIDIENDO C¯. LA RED DE SEGURIDAD
PARA TODOS Ã. SIMPLEMENTE
PIENSO YO Kò ES NECESARIO.
PORQUE, POR EJEMPLO, UN TRABAJO
EN EL CAMPO A TRABAJAMOS CIERTO
TIEMPO, PERO SE TERMINA DE
TRABAJADORES DEL CAMPO SUFREN
MUCHO PARA LA OTRA VEZ OTRO
TRABAJO Y SIENTO QUÊ SOMOS LOS
TRABAJADORES CALLAMOS MUCHAS
GANAS PARA TAMBIÉN ESTAR BIEN
CON ESTE ESTADO. ENTONCES SIENTO
QUÉ ES MERECIDO ESO. GRACIAS.
DISCULPA. NAMASTE. ARQUITOS
ESCUCHADO TENEMOS ESTÁ LAS DOS
EN PUNTO. SI TOMAN MAS TIEMPO
LOS DEMAS VAN A HACER CORTADOS.
SO LO MAS IMPORTANTE ES SU
NOMBRE ORGANIZACION. UN EQUIPO
Â RAPIDO. GRACIAS HI MY NAME IS
GABINO. I'M FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND I'M I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT SAFETY NET FOR ALL. AND
I ASK YOU BECAUSE I AM LIKE A
SEASONAL WORKER. AND WHEN THE
SEASON IS OVER I DON'T HAVE ANY
MORE WORK. AND I WOULD LIKE THAT
HELP. AND WE ARE REALLY WORKING
VERY HARD FOR THIS STATE. THANKS
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS RUBEN
FLORES. I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND WORK AS A SERVER. I'M ASKING
YOU TO INTEGRATE AN INSURANCE
PROGRAM FOR EXCLUDED WORKERS
THROUGH NEXT. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS SUSANNA FREEMAN WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO SOCIAL ORGANIZATION
TUVO LA LA SENADORA PORQUE YO SÉ
QUÊ YENDO CON ESTÁ PETITION Y
VIDAK USTEDES TAMBIÉN C¯ SE TOCA
EN EL CORAZON Y C¯ BIANCA EN
ESTOS DOS, HAY MUCHAS PERSONAS
C¯ NO HAN TENIDO TRABAJO Y LAS
TOCADO MUY PONER EL PANEL A SUS
HIJOS. GRACIAS BUENOS TARDES.
I'M LUCIA AGUILAR MINGO. LA
CIUDAD DE SAN BERNARDINO,
REPRESENTING THE ORGANIZATION
TRABAJADORES DE TRABAJADORES DE
BODEGA Y ESTOY AQUI PARA LA MANO
EN EL CORAZON, PORQUE UNO DE LOS
TRABAJADORES APOYAN LA SEGURIDAD
PARA TODOS. MUCHAS GRACIAS.
TENGA MUY BUENO DÍAS ME NOMBRE
ES VIRGINIA. VENGO DE LA
ORGANIZACION DE LIDERES
CAMPESINOS IN CALIFORNIA Y YO
APOYO A LA SEGURIDAD PARA TODOS
Y EL PROGRAMA DE IGUAL. GRACIAS.
HI. MY NAME IS VIRGINIA AND I'M
WITH LEADERS ARE FIELD LEADERS
AND I'M SUPPORTING SAFETY NET
FOR ALL AND SEE WHAT. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M WITH VALLEY
VOICES FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY,
AND I AM ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
SAFETY NET FOR ALL AND THE
CALIFORNIA WORKPLACE OUTREACH
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. HOLA. BUENAS
TARDES. MY NAME IS TERESA
MOLINA. YO TENGO APOYAR A LA RED
. RED PARA TRABAJADORES ESTEBAN
Y SAN FRANCISCO. HI. MY NAME IS
TERESA MOLINA. I'M COMING FROM
SAN FRANCISCO SUPPORTING SAFETY
NET FOR ALL. HOLA. MUY BUENAS
TARDES. ME NOMBRE ES RAMIREZ
NGUYEN OAKLAND, VIDAK. INTEGRIN
PROGRAMA DE SEGURIDAD DE
TRABAJADORES EXCLUIDOS CHÁVEZ DE
AID. GRACIAS O PERDON.
L'ORGANISATION C¯ MCTV. HI. I'M
COMING FROM MAKITA AND I ASK
PLEASE TO INTEGRATE AND ENSURE
PROGRAM FOR THE EXCLUDED WORKERS
THROUGH EDD. HOLA. ME, SUSANA
TORRES. YOUR BINGO DE LA
AUCKLAND TAMBIÉN TRABAJO PARA LA
ORGANIZACION MCTV Y SOY LA VOZ
DE TODOS TRABAJADORES PUDIERAN
VENIR EVEN IN APOYO PARA LA
RIVAS PARA TODOS. GRACIAS. HI,
I'M COMING FROM OAKLAND. ALSO
I'M CTA AND I'M THE VOICE FOR
ALL THE WORKERS THAT COULDN'T
COME TODAY. AND I'M REALLY
SUPPORTING SAFETY NET FOR ALL.
HI, MY NAME IS RACHEL VAN
TIENHOVEN. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
WORKSAFE AND CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WORKER POWER
OFFERING A ME TOO FOR SAFETY NET
FOR ALL AND SWAP. HELLO, MY NAME
IS ELBA VAZQUEZ. I WORK FOR
MONUMENT IMPACT. WE ARE IN
CONCORD, CALIFORNIA, AMONG THE
MANY PROGRAMS WE OFFER, WE HAVE
A DAY LABOR CENTER WITH OVER 50
MEMBERS. I AM HERE TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE INTEGRATE AN INSURANCE
PROGRAM FOR ALL THOSE ESSENTIAL,
BUT UNFAIRLY EXCLUDED
INDIVIDUALS AS CONTRIBUTORS.
EVERYONE DESERVES TO FEEL
PROTECTED AND INCLUDED. THANK
YOU. BUENOS DIAS. ME NÚMERO
VENGO DE SAN FRANCISCO
RESTAURANTE E QUIERO QUÊ APOYAN
SEGURIDAD DE TRABAJADORES A
TRAVÉS DE LINKS. GRACIAS. HI I
AM A RESTAURANT WORKER COMING
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND PLEASE,
IF YOU, SUPPORT SAFETY NET FOR
ALL AND EDT. THANKS GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MIRIAM. I
AM FROM SAN FRANCISCO. I WORK AT
TRABAJADORES UNIDOS WORKERS
UNITED. I'M ASKING THAT YOU
INTEGRATE AN INSURANCE PROGRAM
FOR EXCLUDED WORKERS THROUGH
EDT. NEXT. THANK YOU. BUENOS
DIAS. SERGIO BIÂU IN SAN
FRANCISCO DE TRABAJO. COMO
PANADERO LES VIDAK INTENCIÓN
PROGRAMA DE SEGURO PARA
TRABAJADORES EXCLUIDOS A TRAVÉS
DE DÍAS. HI. I'M COMING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. I'M A BAKER. AND
PLEASE, I ASK YOU TO INTEGRATE
AND ENSURE PROGRAM FOR THE
EXCLUDED WORKERS. READ HOLA.
BUENOS TARDES. ME NOMBRE ES SAN
FRANCISCO. SOY LIMPIADOR DE
CASAS E VENGO PIDIENDO LAWCENTER
UN PROGRAMA DE SEGURO PARA
TRABAJADORES EXCLUIDOS A TRAVÉS
DE EDDIE GRACIAS. HI. I'M COMING
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. I CLEAN
HOUSES AND I ASK YOU PLEASE, TO
INTEGRATE AND ENSURE PROGRAM FOR
THE EXCLUDED WORKERS. READ HOLA.
BUENOS DIAS. ME? NO REINA
AGUILAR DE BINGO DE SAN
FRANCISCO. Â. BINGO DE LA
ORGANIZACION DE TRABAJADORES
UNIDOS NEAR YOU. BINGO A APOYAR
A PARA TODOS C¯ CERRAMOS
DESEMPLEO PARA TODOS
TRABAJADORES INCLUIDOS. GRACIAS
HI. I'M COMING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. I WORK FOR WORKERS
UNITED WITH WORKERS UNITED. AND
PLEASE, IF YOU CAN HELP US WITH
SAFETY FOR ALL, BECAUSE ON THE
UNEMPLOYED BENEFITS, PLEASE.
HOLA. BUENAS TARDES. ME NOMBRE
ES ADRIANA RENDON. VENGO DE SAN
FRANCISCO, CALIFORNIA. ESTOY CON
TRABAJADORES UNIDOS. WORKERS
UNITED E ESTOY PIDIENDO APOYAN A
TRABAJADORES CON UN SEGUNDO
DESEMPLEO A TRAVÉS DE EDDIE
GRACIAS. HI. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS MERRILEES. WITH SOME
PARENT VOICES, AND I SUPPORT
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN SAID
BECAUSE IT'S FAIR, IT PROMOTES
EQUITY AND IT'S RIGHT. THANK
YOU. HI. MY NAME IS JULIET LARA
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. PARENTS
VOICES. SO I'M A SINGLE MOM AND
I CAN'T FIND A FULL TIME JOB
BECAUSE I HAVE A SON THAT I HAVE
TO TAKE CARE OF. SO I SUPPORT
THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL. YEAH.
THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME IS
VANESSA KENNA. I LIVE IN CONCORD
AND WORK IN CONCORD WITH THE
NONPROFIT MONUMENT IMPACT WITH
THE 50 MEMBER DAY LABOR PROGRAM.
LIKE MANY OTHERS, I'M ASKING YOU
TO INTEGRATE AN INSURANCE
PROGRAM FOR EXCLUDED WORKERS
THROUGH THE EDD NEXT. THANK YOU.
CORNELIA LARA, FRESNO,
CALIFORNIA. CENTRAL NATIONAL
TAKASHI CAMPBELL. CAN YOU COME?
YUNANI. CORNELIA, FLORIDA.
VIRGINIA. FRESNO, CALIFORNIA.
MURATSUCHI CENTRO. VIRGINIA.
NEWCOMER. NHIÀU AND. NIA NIA
NIA. SIMPLY UNA TRABAJADORA DE
MACHINA. SIGWA HELLO. MY NAME IS
CORNELIA FLORES. I AM FROM
FRESNO AND I WORK AS A
AGRICULTURE FIELD WORKER. I'M
HERE WITH CENTRO NACIONAL AND
I'M ASKING YOU TO HELP US WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR ALL
AND ALSO WITH THE SEAWALL
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. HOLA. MY
NAME IS NORMA PELAYO ON SAN
FRANCISCO, CØNG. ORGANIZACION DE
TODOS SOMOS UNA COALITION. LES
VIDAK INTEGRANTE DE NUESTRO
SUPUESTO DE CALIFORNIA. UN
PROGRAMA DE SEGURO PARA
TRABAJADORES EXCLUIDOS
INMIGRANTES A TRAVÉS DE DENISE
GRACIA APOYAR A ESTO DE LOS
TRABAJADORES A EXCLUIDOS
INMIGRANTES Y SOMOS EL TEMA DE
PANAY, FLORES GRACIAS. HI, I'M
COMING FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
ASK YOU PLEASE, TO INTEGRATE AN
INSURANCE PROGRAM FOR THE
EXCLUDED WORKERS THROUGH EDD.
AND WE ARE HAVING TODAY THE
MOTTO OF BREAD AND ROSES. BUENAS
TARDES. ME NOMBRE ES ARMANDO
CELESTINO VENGCO, PRESENTACION
DE LA ORGANIZACION CENTRO
NACIONAL PARA EL DESARROLLO EN
FRESNO. APOYO DE USTEDES PARA EL
PROGRAMA DE SEGURIDAD PARA TODOS
SI EL PROGRAMA SIWAT, GRACIAS.
HI, I'M COMING FROM FRESNO WITH
THE CENTRO BINATIONAL AQUINO,
AND I WILL ASK YOU PLEASE, TO
HELP US WITH SAFETY NET FOR ALL
AND SEE WHAT. BUENOS TARDES. ME
NOMBRE ES MAXIMINA IN CALIFORNIA
. Â TRABAJO EN EL CAMPO LES
PIDO CØNG TRÊN UN PROGRAMA DE
SEGURO PARA TRABAJADORES.
EXCLUIDOS A TRAVÉS DE Â DE NET.
AND I'M COMING FROM FRESNO. I'M
A FIELD WORKER. AND PLEASE, I
ASK YOU TO INTEGRATE AN
INSURANCE PROGRAM FOR THE
EXCLUDED WORKERS THROUGH EDD AND
SAFETY NET FOR ALL. THANK YOU.
I'M GOING TO STOP YOU GUYS RIGHT
NOW. WE ARE AT 12:00, BUT I DO
WANT TO SAY THAT THOSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO BE INCLUDED IN EDD
NEXT, JUST SAY ME TOO OUT LOUD.
NO NO NO NO, I CAN'T DO THAT.
THANK YOU. AND THEN IF YOU GUYS
CAN ALSO TRANSLATE THIS FOR US,
IF YOU GUYS WOULD LIKE YOUR
COMMENTS AND STATEMENTS, YOU
GUYS CAN DEFINITELY EMAIL THE,
COMMITTEE Kò THE SUBCOMMITTEE. I
WOULD ALSO KHÓ ASK YOU GUYS,
JUST AS ORGANIZERS, MANY OF YOU
GUYS ARE FROM MY DISTRICT OR
FROM THE BAY AREA, AS WELL AS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, TO BE
ABLE TO REACH OUT TO BOTH
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE LEADERSHIP
TO ENSURE THIS IS PRIORITIZED.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
ALL RIGHT. HAVING HEARD FROM THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MEMBERS,
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS? SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBER ON THE COMMITTEE ASKING
QUESTIONS, THANK YOU ALL TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. AGAIN,
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY, PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US,
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE, NUMBER FIVE
ON CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION IS ADJOURNED